it's really simple I basically don't
trust anything in reality not Authority
not my mind not my perception nothing I
just trust data and numbers and the only
thing I believe in is I don't want to
die Brian Johnson is a successful
entrepreneur who has spent every minute
of the last three years entirely devoted
to not just slowing the aging process
but actually reversing it what if I
tried to become the best in history at
not dying the world champion of not
dying yeah project blueprint involves a
large team of medical experts cost him
$2 million annually and reliably
provokes the ey and suspicion of others
I'm usually the most unrelatable person
at the table so like we think we have
choice we think we have optionality we
don't we are up against survival do you
believe that there's a possibility that
you won't
die
yes
[Music]
unquestionably today's episode is
brought to you by the awesome
organizations that make this show
[Music]
possible
a bit of forewarning before we dive in
however Brian is not without controversy
there's controversy around what he's
doing around project blueprint itself
there's also controversy around his
personal life some of that controversy
is certainly earned some perhaps not
either way there does remain something
undoubtedly fascinating about this guy
that led me to wanting to better
understand both him but more importantly
the why behind this Mission and I wanted
to do it firsthand and this conversation
which was recorded way back in early
November is nothing if not unique it's
one I entreat you to receive with an
open mind and one I believe is going to
leave you thinking a little bit
differently not just about aging but
about Humanity's place in a future hard
to imagine that is far sooner upon us
than we wish to believe
so nice to meet you Brian thank you for
doing this I've been looking forward to
this for a long time and I want to begin
this by saying something up front
which is a bit of an admission on my
part I think that my original kind of
relationship to what you were doing was
a little judgmental it was based solely
on clickbait headlines that I would see
without reading the Articles without
really devoting an adequate amount of
time to truly understand what you were
doing and I think that left me maybe not
dismissive but sort of not that
interested and the more that I've
learned about you the more I've come to
really appreciate what you're trying to
do and also appreciate the extent to
which I think you're misunderstood and
judged in the way that maybe I was
judging you all of which leads to today
because I really I really want to truly
understand what you're up to because I
think on face value it might appear as
somewhat of a vanity project but there's
a lot more going on here so why don't we
begin with your T-shirt it says don't
die that obviously has an obvious
meaning on its face but for you that
means something much more yeah first
thank you that's magnanimous of you to
be that transparent well it's the least
I can do if I expect you to open up the
least I can do is admit you know my own
vulnerabilities yeah it's the most
common experience
of those getting to num me mhm why is
that yeah
um you my reading of history is
that most of us are born into this world
and we never really understand the
systems we're born
into so for example I was born into a
deeply religious community it was the
singular reality I had of existence in
everyone in my community I was in a
fishbowl I had no idea I was in a
fishbowl until I was 21 years
old and so it makes me wonder how many
of the fish bowls I'm in and that's what
I've been trying to do my entire life is
trying to understand where my perception
takes me what I can't see and I think
the default state for humans is we live
in fishbowls we don't understand what we
don't know and this endeavor is pretty
different to everything else going on in
the world and I think when that happens
the propensity is just a need reaction
to reject it so I I can't speak for
everyone on this but yeah it's been
pretty uh ferocious in a response it's
not been a laxidasical thing it's been
yeah it's been
ferocious I have noticed that you've
become somewhat Adept at uh at tackling
the critics though and you seem to be
having fun with it you know what I mean
like I've seen an evolution in how you
communicate publicly with respect to
that rather than avoid it you're kind of
confronting it head on and doing it in a
playful way yeah yeah the the key is
that most people feel strangled by
adversity and by critics they feel like
that's something that dunks them under
the water and that will somehow defeat
them and they are more apprehensive to
take on trolls and it's really
counterintuitive the best strategy is to
always say yes and if somebody makes fun
of you yes and someone makes a dig at
you yes and and it's so counterintuitive
because you want to defend yourself
that's what you want to do and you want
to make the counter points it's a losing
strategy every single time you never win
and so lean into it and you then take
away the power of those who are trying
to do it and you just play it creates an
environment where your ideas and your
endeavors can
Thrive well I think anytime anybody is
trying to do something new or different
or somebody like yourself is uh you know
putting themselves out there very openly
publicly and transparently in an effort
to do something no one has ever done
before not only to extend your lifespan
but perhaps even reverse your biological
age you're going to open yourself up to
a lot of criticism that's to be expected
of course yeah so on the one hand it's
perhaps the most audacious goal in the
history of Humanity on the other hand as
somebody who has a history of being an
ultra endurance athlete I have a lot of
respect for anyone who's willing to
flirt with the outer edges of human
possibility and I think we've seen even
in recent years in my own little
subculture of ultra endurance some you
know massive gains in terms of what
humans are capable of athletically or
what they're able to endure it wasn't
that long ago when people thought
running a marathon was the furthest
anybody could possibly run they wouldn't
even let women do it and until recent
decades because they thought it would be
too harmful to them and now 100 mile
races are selling out you know my friend
Harvey Lewis just ran 450 miles over
like 96 hours without barely sleeping so
there is a ceiling being raised in terms
of receptivity to human capability yeah
but we are locked into this idea around
the inevitability of our aging and so I
want to give you the opportunity to kind
of let's just you know basically Define
our terms here so people who don't know
who you are and don't know what you're
up to can kind of understand the goals
that you have set for yourself yeah okay
I'll first say all right when when you
and I woke up today okay let me ask you
this question what is your number one
priority
today number one not number two actually
let say number zero number zero priority
not even number one zero PRI um H the
zero thing that has to be done above all
well I have to survive the day I have to
live right but I don't think about that
exactly so your zeroth principal goal
every single second is to not die so you
inhale air as an effort to not die you
then you do other things like you look
both ways before you cross the street
you throw out multi food you wear a seat
belt so all day long that is your your
your zeroth principal goal to not sure
but I wouldn't say that I devote a lot
of conscious resources to the idea of
surviving the day exactly so it's not
top of mind uh because in our daily
lives we play this game every day and we
do things incrementally to get better at
it so for example when it's discovered
that getting hit and run over by a car
uh produces death it spreads throughout
the human race this is a bad thing to do
and therefore we create these habits of
looking both ways across the street we
have lights we have stop signs so we
create these mechanisms and systems to
say how do we not die as a society so
society's built around this concept of
don't die and based upon that principle
I had did this thought experiment when I
was 21 years old I should back up a
little bit I came back from Ecuador I
was a missionary there and I had been
living among extreme poverty and dirt
floors mud huts and it was such a
shocking experience that I had come from
this middle class family in the United
States you know like my mom made my
clothes for me we didn't have a ton of
money but like still I wasn't we were
not fighting for Basics on a daily basis
I came back and I was really questioning
my reality on every level and the only
thing I can make sense of is that I
wanted to spend my life trying to
improve the human race in a meaningful
way I had no idea what that meant I
wasn't good at anything I wasn't a
standout anything so I thought I'll just
make a whole bunch of money by age of 30
and then with money go out and do
something interesting so lucky me I sold
brentry venmo for $800 million on the
eve of that I thought okay now I'm flush
with cash what do I do and so now you
have this basically unlimited option
space you can do anything in the world
with the amount of money I had what do
you do and it's such a challenging
thought process did you find yourself
indulging in your wealth and and kind of
playing that out to see if that would
you know resolve any existential crisis
that you might be having at the time I
did a few things I I really enjoy
outdoor adventure and so I did some dog
sledding across the Sweden I did some
racing in the deserts of Morocco I did
some Iceland Adventure so I kind of did
some outdoor stuff but outside of that
no I really you didn't buy a Bugatti and
a private jet or anything like that I
did get my pilot's license and I started
flying airplanes but for functional
reasons uh money has never really been
anything that really interests me it's
yeah it's it's really not a priority for
me so economics no longer being a factor
in your life this desire or or kind of
compulsion to do good or Advance
humanity is pretty open-ended like how
do you then take your life and your
copious resources and point them in a
Direction that's going to fulfill that
sense of purpose that you have the
choices are endless yeah so how do you
arrive at this idea of healthspan
extension the first thought I had it
came back to when I was 21 years old
discovering that I was in a bubble in
this religious bubble that i' had grown
up this reality had been created for me
we should just say I mean you grew up in
a Mormon Community yeah very
indoctrinated in that religion that's
right Mormonism is not a chill religion
right it's all consuming for your
reality were you in Salt Lake or were
you in like a small smaller a small town
yeah it's more intense the further you
get away from Salt Lake yeah exactly and
everyone in my community there were
30,000 people in my town I don't
remember knowing a single non-mormon
they were probably there I just didn't
know them so everyone shared a singular
understanding of existence and you have
the rules so it's like it's kind of like
this thing where the religion says
here's the rule set and if you play by
them you get this eternal life that's SP
that's spectacular all you have to do is
play by the rules so as a kid it's like
that's a pretty good deal right I can
obey rules I can do that you then become
part of this culture and you forget
you're playing the game you just are the
rules it's very hard to identify that
you're actually in the game so when did
that begin to fracture for you so I
served a mission uh in Ecuador which
even hardened my beliefs even more and
then I came back and I was 21 years old
and even on the mission I started for
the first time really thinking about the
religion cuz before is more of a
cultural thing of I was embedded in the
community was more of a practice and
there you're deep in the doctrine and I
started asking questions like this
doesn't make any sense like how how do I
reconcile this but the challenge was
half my brain was intellectually engaged
in that and half my brain was
emotionally engaged with what I had done
and I was of a split brain it was very
hard for me to discern what I really
thought and felt about it the religion
largely talks about how you feel about a
given thing that God communicates via
this emotional language like you feel
you know the holy spirit in doing these
things so it's very confusing because
you're trying to deduce like what is
truth how do I discern truth is it a
logic train is it an emotion train and
then you have to reconcile those two
things and you have to then say I only
believe in logic that's the only way I
can derive any kind of objective view of
the world and then there's this
emotional Cloud it's like but really is
there such a thing as intuition and
emotion and other ways to receive truth
and so as a as a kid trying to parse
reality especially when you've been in
that your entire life it's very hard to
understand what is really going on so
when when did that begin
to open up for you like was there a
specific event or set of circumstances
where you began to feel like you needed
to put some space between you and this
Doctrine yeah I read a biography of
Joseph Smith the founding prophet of
Mormonism uh rough Stone Rolling and I
think it was written by a member of the
church so historian I think at Columbia
if I'm not mistaken and it was a
historically accurate account of Joseph
Smith and it was the first time I
learned the true history of the Mormon
church because when you grow up into it
you get this washed up version of this
this cleancut set of events where like
you have good guys and bad guys and you
read the history and it's boy it's
complicated and it's not clear-cut and
so I read that I thought this is really
weird because I've trusted these people
my whole life to tell me the truth at
any cost like I trust you to act in my
best interest and I read this I thought
wait a second this is not a relationship
of Integrity I would have expected you
to tell me exactly what happened so I
could pars this myself not clean up the
whole thing and give me some version my
trust started decaying in the
institution like I can't trust you to
tell me things anymore because you have
an agenda to tell me things a certain
way and it just started falling apart
from there yeah that must have been
confusing it's
excruciating there's one thing that's
abundantly clear with the Mormon church
chur in these Mormon communities uh
which is that if you are to break ranks
or part ways uh with the faith you're
risking your connection with that
Community yeah like there's a lot at
stake there's a there's a gigantic
social cost that comes with deciding
that you no longer want to participate
yeah this has been really relevant in
recent years so uh I had three children
with a woman that was Mormon still is
Mormon we separated and at the time my
oldest son was I think 10 is that
talmich uh Jefferson uhhuh yeah all very
young and in that moment it kind of
replayed my childhood where my father
left the church very early on I was
three and he was on his way out but
growing up he was always painted by the
community as a bad guy a guy who
couldn't be trusted he was on the
outside of the community the devil must
surely be whispering in his ear he must
surely be my greatest threat of pulling
me outside and so he was always held at
arms length now my father didn't help
himself by some of the things he did
where like he could have been put
himself in a better spot still he was
other and he was outside the trust
Circle and so when that happened the
same thing happened to my children where
I became other there I was like having
devoted 10 years of my life to try to be
the very best dad I could I was super
attentive I mean I was really devoted to
be a good father the event happens and
now my kids are wondering is Dad okay is
Dad a good guy or bad guy and it caused
this Rift by you know probably six or
seven years where the kids were like I
don't know and they didn't trust me when
they with me it was all this there was
this tension we got along really well my
kids and I we've never actually gotten
into a fight we we get it along really
really well but there was just this
tension where they could never cross to
fully engage with me again that they
could trust me now Talmage uh my my
middle child when he was 16 years old he
left his mother's house and came to live
with me just be like hey I'm with you
Dad let's go so he made the transition
but with the other two kids like it's
still kind of this mixed thing where I I
almost lost them as children you know
where it's like I can't be their father
in a way where I could
before yeah that has to be additionally
painful you despite your best efforts to
be such a good dad repeating a pattern
that your dad did and whatever pain that
that must have caused you as a young
child confusion about your relationship
with your dad and your dad struggled
right like he had substance issues and
all kinds of things right he did which
makes for a bit of a confusing childhood
you know I'm trying to tie a
relationship
between the experience you had as a
young person in the church with your
father you know being painted in a
certain way and then out of the house
and having his struggles to the mission
that you're on now and I have to believe
on some level there was some trauma that
you suffered as a result of this and
typically when there's chaos like that
there's an Impulse in the traumatized
person to want to exert control over
their life right because they're used to
being things being out of out of control
so it would make sense that you're
living a life that is so I mean to say
your life is regimented is to completely
underestimate the the manner in which
you you know pursue each day but is it
fair to say that there must be some
connection between those two things like
I'm trying to understand part of the
motivation for how and why you live the
way that you do so my perception of
myself which I give very little weight
to you know like you can observe me
probably much more clearly than I can
observe myself so having said that my
perception is that my upbringing taught
me to not trust
anything the authorities that I trusted
with My Soul failed me my community
failed me now their responsibility was
not to help me acquire awareness of all
possible realities of different
religions of different ways of being of
a history that was not their objective
their objective was to keep me in the
fold with this singular understanding
that said it led me to believe to
distrust all authority and then the
second beat which I think was relevant
is
when I was 24 years old I became
chronically depressed I got married we
had a new baby I was building a startup
full-time I wasn't getting much sleep
and I think the stress and the
relationship and all that kind of stuff
just kind of broke me for a little bit
and I didn't take care of it and I just
sunk into this dark depression and in
that moment you know my brain is now
squawking life is not worth living uh
everything's terrible you should
probably end your life and those who've
had depression just knows this is just
on repeat like it just pummels you every
second of every day
with these thoughts about ending your
life and so I genuinely am empathetic to
people who commit suicide it is a
rational thing to do totally get it like
I've been there I I've been to that very
edge so at this point I'm coming from
just trust of authority in my life at
this point I don't trust my mind like my
mind is telling me to end my life but
when it tells me to do other things why
do I trust it so now I think how can I
trust anything in
reality including your own mind
including my own mind I nothing my mind
says am I going to believe certainly we
all filter reality through a lens of
perception yeah and we convince
ourselves that what we're perceiving is
is truth when in fact you have a more
kind of well-honed appreciation for the
fact that perception is opinion at best
right we can't trust what we're being
told we can't necessarily trust what our
mind is telling us and extrapolating
upon that gets into this whole very
interesting notion that you have which I
agree with which is this culture of
addiction from the very first moment
that we're born we're exposed to
impulses and marketing messages and
temptations incessantly throughout our
life every single moment of every single
day luring us into habits and behaviors
and beliefs that not only don't serve us
but are orthogonal to our well-being
yeah yeah that's exactly right so
elaborate on that a little bit one day I
read this book the economics of Life by
Gary Becker he's a Nobel prizewinning
Economist from the University of Chicago
and he did a series of essays for I
think Newsweek and he explained social
phenomena in mathematical terms so he
take a topic like religion and normally
you'd go about explaining religion with
a story but he would just say
numerically here's how you understand it
this is also made Popular by
Freakonomics where you take and you look
at the numbers behind so he exposed this
world of math and models and equations
and it was one of the most spectacular
experiences of my entire life because my
entire reality before was story this
person did this thing in this way and
you feel this emotion and you make this
perception then you do this thing and
now he's saying numerically you can
understand reality and I was like this
is the coolest thing I've ever seen in
my entire life so I'm coming from this
little teeny town I don't meet an
engineer until I'm like 22 years old I
don't have a computer I have no access
to technology or the world of
engineering so this discovery that you
can understand the world numerically is
just like this mind-blowing experience
for me so I go to the University of
Chicago I study there and I fully
appreciate this way of understanding the
world and as I've gone about my life
this is I get to don't die it's really
simple I basically don't trust anything
in reality not Authority not my mind not
my perception nothing I just trust data
and numbers and the only thing I believe
in is I don't want to die outside of
that you know like I'll go play around
and like say this and that but if I
really try to say like what what can I
distill my existence down to I enjoy
being alive right now and I don't want
to be dead in 5 minutes I don't want to
be dead in 10 minutes I don't want to be
dead tonight now what's going to happen
100 years from now I don't know but
that's what I've really tried to do
because otherwise life is just so messy
it's so hard to understand what's really
going on it's hard to understand what to
do it's hard to understand how to
resolve conflict it's just it's just
messy and it's chaotic and so I try to
distill this down into In This Moment In
Time in 2023 and this goes back to what
I was trying to do for for the
species if you ask this singular
question you can do you you can do one
thing
with your existence and you try to
uplevel the human race or or make a
contribution to the human race what do
you do and that's what I just spent 10
years trying to figure
out to go from the Mormon church with
its Doctrine around the afterlife uh to
a place of making data and numbers your
godhead is is quite a transition right
like I'm I can't help but Wonder like
what is the nature of your relationship
with spirituality is that a thing
because I think for for all of your
Fidelity
to to data sets you are a deeply
emotional person you wouldn't be doing
what you're doing if you didn't have
this connection to the future of
humanity and if you thought Nothing Else
Matters except what is happening right
now then why would you devote your life
towards advancing something that perhaps
you're not going to reap the benefit
from yeah I guess uh school never really
made sense to me because the class was
so slow the teacher monologue was so
slow the idea of memorizing information
and regurgitation just didn't appeal to
me I hated school it was just the worst
I would have rather be home and read a
dozen books in the same time frame and
once I freed myself from school I sat
out and I just read every biography I
get my hands on I enjoyed the process of
looking back through the centuries and
looking at individuals in their time and
place the 14th century the 15th 16th you
know even before ad and trying to
evaluate what did they do in their time
in place what did they see that no one
else could see and how did they do it
like what was the dominant cultural
Trends in their time what were the ideas
that were novel what were the ideas
being rejected and I built this
relationship with historical figures
where I cared more about being friends
with them than I cared about being
friends with people in the present
because most people in the present were
playing games that I didn't really care
about you know it it's largely about
social signaling and Status everything
that plays in this in this moment but
99% of what happens right now is going
to be lost to history that's true for
the past when you look at the 15th
century our history books only capture
you know less than 1% of all the events
that happened everything else was washed
away I liked the idea of doing something
that would contribute to this continuous
stream of contribution for the human
race and so I built this relationship
along this time span and so even looking
forward I feel more committed to or
connected with intelligence of the 25th
Century than I do right now I care more
about what they're going to say of me
than what people say of me
now because it takes time for history to
kind of to steal what happens to me
that's the game I want to play those are
the people I think about when
contemplating what to do it's more than
first principles thinking you have this
proclivity for having a bird's eye
10,000 foot view like your timeline is
longer your altitude is higher and that
requires not only a deeper way of
thinking uh but also perhaps a Divergent
way of thinking right like you do think
differently there is something maybe
slightly neurod Divergent about how you
view the world do you have awareness
around that is that is that fair is that
is that accurate do you think it's such
a fun question you my experience of
reality is when I engage with other
people you know I observe like what
you're doing is nuts you like I it's
like insane to me and then their
perception of me is like hey are you
maybe aware you may be a bit neurode
Divergent and so there's this swapping
of percep
and there's this default where when you
use the word neurod Divergent it
encumbers that person to be like that
person is odd therefore maybe slightly
uh like they get discounted a little bit
versus the norm and so there's this
perception game going on where I view
the world as literally insane but I know
people view me as like huh that's a bit
different I'm not quite sure what to
think about that
I don't mean the word neurod Divergent
in a pejorative way I truly mean it in
the purest sense of somebody who is
seeing things differently and thinking
about them differently and I think you
do and and I think the world is insane
but we're so inoculated you know we're
so
indoctrinated into these Norms that it's
very difficult to even identify them let
alone challenge them yeah so my comment
was nothing about the way you were using
the term I'm saying generally when I
hear people talking about neurod
Divergence I get that it's always with
just a slightly pejorative tinge yeah
yeah I understand it's always like it's
just a slight knock of like you know but
we'll be nice to them anyways it just
has this cultural phenomena in
conversation so yes I'm absolutely aware
of this I have full self-awareness of
the situation I go to dinner with
friends right and and I hear everyone
talking and I'm like whoa I really am so
different in how I think so definitely
have the self- awareness also I I think
that this is the attribute that I see
most common in the biographies I read
these individuals throughout history
they were able to structure their ways
of thought in ways that were unique they
were able to see the world differently
able to act differently they able to
rise above the norms and Status Quo and
expectations of their time and place and
this is why I say I feel so much more
connected to people of the past and my
imaginations of people in the future I
feel at home on this Spectra and why I
feel almost alien in this time and place
because when I do my things we've seen
this it creates this vitriol where it's
like we're not sure if we want to
welcome you to our polite Society like
we're not sure like we actually want to
dunk on you we want to push you away and
we want to criticize you we want to
lower your status by saying the meanest
things we can that's really what's been
happening is if you look at the volume
of trash talk of me it's meaningful and
and you people are having fun with it
which is great I'm having fun with it
too but it's also it's as humans play
power games they're trying to take me
down a notch they're trying to reduce my
[Music]
power the science is in people hot and
cold therapy in other words using sauna
and cold water immersion has so many
powerful benefits like lowering
inflammation reducing muscle soreness
boosting energy and elevating mood but
the thing is DIY ice baths are this
colossal Hassle and basically just
impractical making the whole Affair
unsustainable which is a problem solved
by the guys of plunge who pioneered the
all-in-one solution this gorgeous
elegant modern tub that's easy to
install indoors or out with Cooling and
filtration built right into it so it
basically requires almost zero
maintenance and I use it almost every
single day which has greatly impacted my
physical health and I got to say vastly
improved my mental wellbeing the plunge
team now also offers a beautiful sauna
for the ultimate hot cold experience
this gorgeously designed Edition to your
space I got mine up and running recently
and I got to say I can no longer imagine
life without it it really has been an
absolute GameChanger for my physical
health of course but also all these
profound benefits to my mental
well-being to learn more and get your
own cold plunge tub or sauna visit
plunge. comom and hit the link in the
description below and use code Rich Roll
to get $150 off your
purchase anytime anybody's taking a bold
step to do something different they're
going to be AC cross purposes with
social norms so for you that's just
affirmation right that you're on a
trajectory towards you know the
aspiration of being one of those
historical figures and when you think
about those people or those biographies
that were most impactful like who are
the people that that stand out
it's such a great variety I just
finished up mellan you know first person
to circum navigate the globe and if you
read about it it's like the world was
going crazy on this idea of trade routes
and spices and all the things it's just
like every boom cycle we have right now
like Humanity just plays this game over
and over and over again it's the same
thing we think we're playing this new
novel game it's not it's been played for
thousands of years so melan is really
fun I finished up a book on dietr Bon
Hofer he was a religious person in
Hitler's World War II Germany and he was
trying to assassinate Hitler so in that
moment I was so curious because you can
read about World War II about this Army
doing that thing and Church Hill doing
this and like those moves but I wanted
to understand if you're in World War II
Germany and Hitler's rising to power
what's happening like how do you discern
is this person good for Germany or bad
for Germany do you understand what he's
suggesting for the Jews or do you not
understand do you hear secrets about it
like I want to understand real time and
place what was happening and his account
of how he was basically scheming to
assassinate Hitler and all the
maneuvering thereabouts that was just
fascinating for me because that's a very
cloudy time in my mind how does Hitler
rise to power how does that thing happen
how does the world know or not know and
do something about it so uh those kind
of things I I really enjoy reading about
that to understand it in detail right
the frog in in the water that's that
slowly boils you're in a situation
that's creepy being in a certain
direction but because you're a
participant in it you're not you don't
have the adequate awareness to
understand what's truly happening
exactly this is the most exciting thing
for me so if we play this game right now
and you and I say ask this question in
this
moment what is really going
on like really really going on what's
happening what's really going on and now
to do this the first 20 thoughts we have
we probably have to just push aside
because they're probably garbage we have
to like really sit in this thing and
that's the only chance you have a
Clarity of thought after I still brain
Tre VMO I organized a dozen or so
dinners around the country got my
friends together their friends are
friends and just wanted to bring
together ambitious people and I gave
them this thought experiment let's
imagine we're in 2050 at the time is
2017 we arrive at 2050 we are thriving
as a species like it's just this magical
existence what did we focus on in 2017
to make that a reality and I wanted to
tease out like what are the intuitions
and probably predictably you would
imagine that you you basically hear
clusters of thought that represent the
modern zist it was very very rare for
someone to come up with something
contrarian you know like something that
someone wouldn't just pull out of the
zist but it was really helpful
nonetheless to just kind of find like
where are people's minds at right now
where do they think trajectories are
heading so I really wanted to seed I
wanted to seed my own thoughts on like
what is happening now where do people
think things are going and then you have
to put do the hard work of now what is
no one seing mhm and what is no one
seeing what did you extrapolate from
that experience it was a single thought
experiment which led me to what I'm
doing now whether I'm right or wrong
we'll see but a conviction to move
forward it's I'm present with
intelligence of the 25th
Century I can't say they're talking so I
don't know how that communication works
but just there's this essence of
intelligence and they're observing what
happened in the early 21st century to
make intelligent existence thrive in
this part of the Galaxy
what do they observe so in the same way
we look at the 16th century and we kind
of compress the entire Century down to
like four things or five things it's a
very intense compression and the
observation I thought they they said is
homo sapiens figured out on the eve of
the creation of super intelligence that
the only foe was
death they figured out to turn all their
attention to not dying don't die
individually don't kill each other don't
destroy the
planet and build AI in a way that
enables all intelligence to
thrive that's the biggest revolution in
the history of the human race because it
challenges that death has always been
inevitable so it challenges that
fundamental thing and two it challenges
every game of status and power we've
ever played if you wanted to rise above
your peers before you'd raise an army go
kill people and acquire their territory
it's always been rooted in this violence
and acquisition at uh one person's gain
and another person's loss you have to
transition the entirety of the species
to say we're going after different games
and uh that's when I yeah I started
doing blueprint I thought so
philosophically you can say this but it
doesn't matter you actually have to be
it for people to understand it there's
so much in what you just shared I want
to tease out a few things that came up
for me the first of which is the
presumption which is increasingly
becoming more and more real with every
single day that artificial intelligence
uh is going to
become not just an overarching kind of
aspect of how we live our lives but in
your case almost an all powerful entity
that is benevolent by nature to which we
then Outsource all of our decision
making that are brains you know we've
relied on our brains since the dawn of
humanity so that the artificial
intelligence can make better decisions
in our best interest and in the best
interest of the collective and the
planet as a whole that requires a very
optimistic view of this emerging
technology amidst a lot of discourse
around its perils and its potentiality
to actually do the opposite of what
you're projecting yeah so a few examples
I just did this AI
art to retell the story of Adam and
Eve so I wanted to pose the question if
we retold our origin story right now
instead of thousands of years ago right
now in 2023 what would the origin story
of Adam and Eve be like and how would we
project ourselves out and I thought that
was an interesting thought experiment
because it gets at exactly what you
talked about which is if you look at the
Precedence where the first time a
message was sent with a telegraph the
Pony Express was dead nobody wanted to
run melano with horses it was so much
better the first time you could navigate
with GPS a paper map on your lap is
dead it's just inevitable like we don't
do these things because it's more
efficient when you can wash your
clothing in a washing machine versus
down at the river so you look at these
hundreds of examples of where technology
becomes sufficiently good at doing a
given task it's more efficient or cost-
effective or whatever the case may be we
humans adopt it extremely fast
I'm arguing with my health and wellness
that my team and I have built an
algorithm that takes better care of me
than I can myself it is able to look at
all the data in my body it's looking at
scientific evidence it creates an
algorithm so it creates Superior
cognitive ability Superior metabolic
ability Superior physical ability All
Above I am a superior human because it's
algorithm so I have two options do I say
I'm going to do things I did and go Prov
my pantry am I going to make decisions
on the menu no like I'm going to choose
the algorithm just like I use GPS like a
washing machine and like I use autopilot
on airplane and so it's inevitable that
when these thing cross a technological
threshold and they allow each of us to
achieve our goals we adopt them
instantaneously up until that point we
kick and scream we talk about lost jobs
we talk about the fear like it's a
process every single time it happens but
we ruthlessly adopt them and so that's
just what's going to happen it's
absolutely
inevitable the picture also paints a
very
authoritarian view that obviates human
choice right like you're you're lobbying
for a world in which there's an AI that
has your best interest at heart it's
going to tell you exactly what to eat
when to go to bed all of your decision
making is outsourced to this thing that
will produce better outcomes for you but
with that becomes a relinquishment of
some level of Liberty that many people
would you know count or argue undermines
the the beauty of living right so your
response to that is yeah this is the
dinner I invited you to oh it was who
else was there what did I miss I'm sorry
I missed that no it's it's been it's um
uh it's been remarkable the people so
I've had this dinner over a dozen times
and so I pose this thought experiment
and I say okay so imagine you have an
algorithm at your disposal it creates
the best health and wellness of your
life spiritually mentally physically all
the above you can say yes to that the
trade-off is you eat what it says it
will you go to bed when it says says it
will like you you follow the instr you
can't opt out once you're in that's it
well I mean so I don't even make that
parameter I don't get that specific it's
just very general so I create the
thought experiment and we go around the
table there's like 12 of us at this
point like we're pretty intimate we
understand each other and so it's
mathematically it's almost identical
every time so a third of the people say
yes anything to save Me For Myself like
I can't stop myself from doing blank
blank blank so like yes another 30% yeah
are like um hey yes but um I want to
make a few modifications and I'm like
LOL that's not the thought experiment
the human desire for the alart version
of Blue part is undefeated I'm sure
right exactly and then the remaining you
know let's just call it 40% are kind of
like [__]
off and so like you gave me a pretty
soft [__] off because you basically
raising like look just raising the
argument that I'm sure you hear a
million times to hear how you respond to
that but like you it's legit cuz you're
basically like look look I've got human
agency this is the thing I understand I
want to choose to live life a certain
way I've got certain ideals and what it
means to live life I've got plans like
it just it trips every wire in the human
brain where it's so offensive that's why
people like they don't even know some
response would be like is this a cult
you know like yeah like it just
generates these really strong responses
and so I'm not lobbying for this I'm
arguing it's inevitable it's already
here we're wasting time on these debates
this is not a situation where we're like
we're in full control and we're going to
decide how this thing it's not like it's
gone and so what I'm suggesting is if we
can reconcile philosophically with
what's happening we are going to be in a
better place to the species we increase
the probabilities of our survival right
now we're in la la land thinking that
we're somehow in control of the whole
situation
H I can't decide whether I'm excited or
terrified exactly yeah I'll fast forward
two hours for you so at the end of the
conversation we go around and everyone's
able to basically be like okay so like
here's my emotional state here's my
concern here's my philosophical position
and you like the same 20 or 30 arguments
are presented every time we go back and
forth we look at all the different
angles so then and then people have like
three or four existential crisises you
know they drop down it's like I don't
know why I exist and they come back up
at the end gladly everyone hugs it's
like this is one of the best experiences
of my life I'm so happy we got to do
this together they're exchanging numbers
so it ends up being this incredibly
emotionally productive thing where we
all get to reconcile our various views
of reality not that we agree but just
like we can reconcile with like here's
maybe the situation what is the thing
that helps the most resistant person
come to terms with what you're
forecasting as the inevitable reality so
I'm usually the most unrelatable person
at the table uhhuh
so like I'm not surprised
what I say doesn't really matter and
resonate so it's like when someone else
is able to take these ideas and maybe
they get their head around a little bit
they're like I think this and they say
it in some relatable way the person's
like oh that's kind of interesting but
it's like never me that delivers up the
relatable thing that people are like
okay I'm actually okay with that thing
it's a slow walk to just understand the
basics of they perceive themselves of as
having full control right now in reality
they live in several AI bubbles the
content they see on YouTube the music
they listen to what they see on Netflix
the books they read you know they're
recommended to them like we have all
this algorithmic influence around us
already and we just don't talk about it
but it's dramatically influenced you
know what we see what we see on social
media and we understand that one we're
already in the whole bunch of these webs
and two is as technology progresses we
do adopt them in our lives like
unquestionably because it helps us
achieve the things things we care about
and once we do that adoption we feel
empowered and so if you just look at the
landscape of our lives today we already
say yes to this we have said yes to this
our lives are evidence of that and so
it's not a big jump to what I'm saying
it's just really it's trying to bring it
out to the open and say can we have a
discussion about this and if we are open
about it we may actually build a more
robust
system part of that involves popping the
the balloon the delusion of agency that
I think we like we believe we have m
agency in our decision making and our
opinions and our beliefs and our sense
of of what is true and what is real
right so you're challenging that y
cogently by disabusing people of that
notion and I think on top of that like
look
I'm I'm deeply aware of and connected to
the fact that like my brain doesn't have
my self-interest at hard like I'm a
recovering
alcoholic food addict been you know in
the gutter I've been you know overweight
and out of shape and left to my own
devices like I'm going to bury my head
in that bag of chips like every single
time and I'm going to make the wrong
choices and I've had to create
incredibly stringent rules for myself
guard rails to avoid the Temptations
that are overpowering for me and perhaps
you know maybe more overpowering for me
than they are for an average person or
or somebody else and I've been
successful in that regard but I'm highly
flawed and I you know I'm not always
great at doing this and I'll mess up and
so my life has become regimented not to
the extent that yours is like I'm a poor
man's version of of your experiment but
it's all been informed
by my
experiences with the limitations of my
brain which don't have my best
interested heart and that has to be
overridden by not allowing myself to
have an opinion about certain things so
rules are very binary and that makes
them easier to follow I'm not
Outsourcing them to an artificial
intelligence but by making that choice
and that declaration it is easier to
kind of adhere to those guard rails I
suppose you've just taken this you know
a thousand degrees further yeah and I
would pause and say I really enjoy being
here with you oh thank you yeah I really
am misunderstood and it is
extraordinarily challenging to get to
this level of conversation MH and so I
appreciate you going here with me I just
really appreciate the back and forth
thank you and especially your
acknowledgement of your own
limitations it is uh so rare for for
someone to observe in
themselves the disaster situation it is
to be human and like we're all just
barely on a thread so yeah I guess I'm
just really appreciative that we have a
chance to talk about this thank you
that's meaningful I appreciate that
yeah listen we delude ourselves into
thinking that we're our own best friend
and and most often at least in my case
I'm My Own Worst Enemy like constantly
even with the the kind of narratives
that Loop in my mind about who I am and
what I'm capable of like it's terrible I
wouldn't do that to anybody else and I
think having an appreciation for that or
or a really kind of mature understanding
of that allows me to be more
compassionate and less judgmental of
other people because it's [__] hard
to human every single day we're faced
with temptation I mean our modern world
has perfected through science and
experimentation and psychology to create
a landscape of material Goods Foods you
name it every single thing is
specifically designed with gigantic
resources behind it to entice and addict
you yeah for reasons that have nothing
to do with your well-being at all right
and in fact is quite often in opposition
to that yeah amazing and so you're sort
of staking you're putting a flag in the
ground and saying I will not adhere like
I am not living in accordance with these
rules I'm stepping outside of it I'm
going to let a team of very smart people
study me and study what's best for me
and I'm going to let them make those
decisions for myself now certain people
would say well you've created a gilded
cage for yourself but I know through
other interviews that I've watched with
you that you're like the happiest that
you've ever been and I think I want to
hear a little bit more about that and I
will just say in you know prefatory to
that that I think we over index or
overemphasize a sense of happiness that
comes with Choice like I have Liberty so
I'm happy and we underappreciate or
don't appreciate at all that with
certain restrictions or guard rails to
kind of rein Us in and and prevent us
from indulging in our behaviors that
don't serve us there is a certain
underappreciated Freedom that brings a
certain happiness that at least in my
life I haven't experienced in any other
way yeah amazing so I'm going to take
this opening you've created thank you uh
I've never been able to talk about this
on a podcast because it's always about
like what are you eating what your
exercise protocol what time you go to
bed I'm arguing for basically three
things in the early 13 colonies of
America there was a big debate on
whether uh they should be ruled by the
monarch of England or whether they
should adopt uh
democracy and Thomas Payne wrote this
pamphlet and he argued that the colony
should adopt democracy because they
would be better at ruling their own
interests than having the Monarch and he
talked about all the shortcomings of the
Monarch and we now look back and we
think okay democracy is actually one of
the big advancements in the history of
the human race where you had this new
way of governing away from monarchs at
the time it was not clear and this is an
example of history of like what is
really cloudy in that moment how do
people see Clarity his pamphlet was the
bestselling uh of the early American
colony days and democracy prevailed and
in that moment democracy ended up being
a more powerful system of managing uh
human thriving one individual is a
monarch was inferior to this democratic
system I did the same thing with my body
my mind is a monarch in the same way you
just spoke about your mind your
mind is acting contrary to your best
interest my mind is a drunken sailor
exactly it is it's an absolute disaster
and I wholeheartly agree with that I did
the same with my body I said who should
really be in charge the Monarch or
should we have a democratic Rule and
then we started with blueprint we
started measuring every organ of my body
we said okay heart lungs liver pancreas
cardiovascular function what do you need
to be your best self and I let them
speak and I so I shifted the power from
my Monarch mind that's a disaster to my
body to be in charge and that's what the
algorithm works with the algorithm Works
directly with my body what I'm arguing
here for the human race is I'm
suggesting we have always treated our
mind as the ultimate Authority on all
things it decides on in any circumstance
what it wants when it wants how it
thinks what it's going to prioritize it
has ultimate Authority like the Monarch
I'm arguing in this next phase of the
human race that that is an Antiquated
model of management of human life there
are more powerful and more capable
systems of intelligence that are
emergent specifically what I've done
with blueprint empowering my body and
artificial intelligence to manage a self
now do I still have free will I feel
like I do do I still have my same uh
agency I feel like I do am I happier I
feel like I am like but it's this paired
with the challenging of death is the
most significant revolution in the
history of homo sapiens and it is almost
impossible for someone to get their head
around it it takes an hours to sit down
and have a conversation to understand in
this conversation your mind is like
immedi chirping but wait I still bristle
at the idea of Outsourcing everything to
a super intelligence in the same way
that when we have a GPS on our phone or
on our car dashboard we suddenly are
paying less attention to the Topography
of our natural environment because we've
outsourced having to really understand
that when we begin to Outsource more and
more of our
decisions to something out side of
ourselves to play that to its you know
ultimate conclusion is to play out the
paperclip thought experiment except
instead of paper clips it's people so
this could go very wrong in the most
dystopian way what you're arguing
for requires a level of trust and faith
in our ability to craft this super
intelligence in a way that is truly
benevolent but does that not Overlook
the fact that perhaps it might have its
own ideas about how that might
go I'm
suggesting that we have no
choice we think we have choice we think
we have
optionality we don't we are up against
survival I understand your emotion of
bristling that's what happens every
single time and it it does it takes a
long time to get past the bristle this
is the same as the Monarch it's the same
Revolution your mind is a monarch that
does a terrible job managing your best
interest you know this and even knowing
this even telling me in this
conversation you still bristle with the
idea that this thing wouldn't be in
charge of you that you don't trust at
all you know it's bad for you and you
bristle still the enemy you know it's so
complicated so if you take yourself out
of the situation and you're observing
someone
else isn't it
curious that yeah the enemy you do know
is working towards your demise and your
basically power is against it and
there's another technology another way
of doing this that saves you from
yourself would you be open to
that it sounds like an invitation to
join the Matrix like just like I want to
have a nice steak and make me a movie
star yeah you know plug me
in you're like it's happening I mean so
just let's look at the past thousand
years we live day-to-day so time seems
slower to us but if you look at the
speed of technological progress the rate
is aign straight up over it's
astronomical right now it's straight up
so like whether we're talking about one
year or five years or 10 years or 20
whatever it's absolutely in a blink of
an eye on any time scale that is longer
than our 2-hour
conversation it's
here right now this is why I don't die
when I do the thought experiment of all
the things we can be contemplating about
our
existence if we're trying to avoid a
situation where we annihilate each other
with nukes or bioweapons or anything
else and we're trying to say can we
agree on one thing this one things we
don't destroy the species and continue
to to exist what can we agree upon it's
don't die it's the game every single
human on this planet plays every second
of every day it's the only thing we can
agree upon now people who commit suicide
they're the only ones who don't agree on
that and so there's a few exceptions to
it but generally speaking but outside of
the don't die we Branch into thousands
and thousands of disagreements as a
species we have this wild range of
disagreements about everything that's
why I can press it and say what does the
21st century say about the 21st century
it's the rallying cry for the 21st
century it's the only way to build
AI it's the only the only ethics and
morals is don't die of anything across
the planet now of course it branches
into all kinds of complexity but still
you can start with some agreement
basically how do you stitch together
this moment in time what is really going
on how do you punch through all the
noise and all the chaos and really
figure out what's going on right
now
I still can't shake this idea that
within you is some profound or
deep fear of
death that is not unrelated to your
break with a church that promised
everlasting life and now living living a
life outside of
religion this mission has supplanted or
replaced what used to be provided by the
church is there any truth in that I mean
possibly right as far as my
self-awareness goes kamu the famous
French philosopher he went to the
existential edges of philosophy of of
existentialism and he basically came to
the conclusion you know existence is
meaningless so the only relevant
question is whether you commit suicide
there's nothing else that
matters and once you decide whether you
commit suicide or not if you don't then
you just play in my thought experiment
whether I'm influenced by my past or I'm
bringing like I don't know it's very
very hard for me to comment the only
thing I'm trying to do is distill the
most basic essence of reality to know
one
thing it's not just be wandering about
in the confusion of existence I'm trying
to say one thing is distillation of
essence there's something inescapably
Buddhist in what you're doing though
because this quest to see how far you
can push the boundaries of Hells span is
an experiment
in not just self-preservation but it's a
very kind of singularly focused
experiment on self right so you could
make the argument that this is the most
self-obsessed
person and experiment of all time but
the overlying kind of mission is to do
this for the benefit of humanity and so
it goes to that Buddhist idea of the
best way of improving the world is to
improve yourself and if you can be a
model for what is possible that becomes
a template for others
to modify or copy right yeah I tried to
become the problem that I'm trying to
solve in society so we hear a lot of
discussion about uh AI goal alignment so
the idea is AI is powerful we want it to
to want what humans want we don't want
it to go Rogue and Hur us and so like
the paper CLI outcome is like avoid that
stuff uh we want nation states to get
along and not nuke each other we want
each other to get along and not kill
each other so Society is basically
trying to goal line right we're trying
to get our on the same page with so many
things and that's hard to do we do a lot
of things to do that I wanted to say can
I become the goal alignment problem
problem so I'm 35 trillion sales Brian
Johnson can I goal Aline my 35 trillion
sales because not all my sales want the
same thing my brain's like hey let's
have a drink and stay up late and party
and so that's what this endeavor has
been is I'm trying to say can I take 35
trillion sales 35 intelligent agents
align it towards a singular objective of
don't die because we have no hope of
getting the whole planet to align on
anything if we can't figure out how to
align ourselves exactly and if I do that
then you the same model is applied to
planet Earth okay so planet Earth is an
amazing place we currently don't have a
backup so how do we make the planet not
die the same concept you take millions
of measurements of planet Earth the soil
and the atmosphere you look at
scientific evidence of what is a
thriving biosphere of coral and and
oceans and air you implement the
protocol and then we humans deal with it
m cuz we currently treat planet Earth
the same way we treat our bodies we do
whatever we want we pollute it how much
we want like if the oceans become more
acidic whatever if we lose coral reef
whatever if we lose the ice Capal
whatever we just destroy it and this
protocol will be dictated by an
allseeing all- knowing authoritative AI
that will rule the planet and create the
protocol us as humans our job is to
carry the protocol out uh it it's just
it's built on just like a stepbystep
process and how we buildt everything
else in society so the authoritarianism
will just creep up on us I wouldn't say
it's authoritarianism I me so is
democracy authoritarianism no it's the
same system you're taking intelligent
agents that are all acting in some
methodology towards goal alignment with
this tapestry of rules and democracy has
outperformed
monarchy my system has outperformed
almost all human
systems we're just simply trying to
elevate the quality of the system
towards don't die it's this very gradual
step
function do you believe that there's a
possibility that you won't die
yes
[Music]
unquestionably that you will live in
perpetuity short of getting into a car
accident something like that yeah you're
not going skydiving anytime soon if we
try to sober ourselves when we
say how
smart is super intelligence you in what
ways smart and how smart how different
is it from
us and if we say okay let's just try to
do a few thought experiments that like
maybe are relatable to us so we a
million years ago talking to Homo rectus
Homo rectus barely has language has an
axe hasn't innovated upon the axe for a
million years and we say homoerectus we
trust you so much we think you're so
amazing you know go wild and tell us
your vision about the future of the
species is homoerectus going to be able
to you know wax poetic about quantum
mechanics and you know thermodynamics
and computers and internet and markets
and money no way so if homus is like you
know what do I want to live for like you
life is so hard I go out and Hunt food
all day and I have to battle all these
wild things and homus has absolutely
nothing valuable to say about the future
of its existence the only thing it can
say is I don't want to die because I
want to be around with the
optionality in this moment where we
exist I don't think our opinions matter
at
all nothing I think nothing I want
nothing I hope for nothing I presume
matters at all we're up against this
wall with intelligence that is just
unimaginable to us so I give zero
Credence to my opinions I'm homoerectus
I'm I'm so primitive it's laughable so
why would I even try to enter into the
situation the only thing I want to say
is I want an option to the to the future
is it going to be good or bad I have no
idea well I like it or not I have no
idea I have no idea I just want to say
yes to it because it's happening and so
I want to I want to be along for the
ride I want to get into the actual
protocol of what you're doing but before
we do that I want to have a sense of of
what the data is currently telling you
and how that plays into this idea or
this belief that you have that the
possibility of
persisting exists for you yeah since I
sold brain stre VMO I I invested uh tens
of millions of dollars in companies that
are programming physical reality so
genomics nanotechnology synthetic
biology computational Therapeutics one
of my companies for example structures
molecule molecule by molecule like Legos
to do novel things in the world we now
have the ability to program the physical
world with atoms and molecules and
organisms like we can program computer
software we can program reliably program
reality in every way possible it's the
most unbelievable situation in the whole
world and we're doing this now with
these computational tools that are more
powerful what would be an example of
that that feels very abstract like um
let's say you want to produce rose oil
as a fragrance so typically you would go
plant the plants in the field you would
fertilize it you'd water it you'd
Harvest it then You' get the rose oil
the alternative is to take a yeast an
organism and program the yeast to
manufacture rose oil mhm or the way we
build houses now is we grow a tree we
cut it down we then put it in a certain
place and we build a house you would
just grow a house out of a tree You'
program it m and so you can program
biology to do the things that we
otherwise would do other ways and that's
how powerful our ability is to engineer
biology and and reality so we have this
root level access to program these
things that's my companies have been
doing for the past 10 years it's
unbelievable yeah it's like it's so
amazing that it's happening and it's
like no one knows about it that we have
these abilities to do it it's yeah it's
really cool
so if you say okay we now have the
ability to basically engineer existence
at every level molecules and organisms
and atoms and now you have these new
computational tools and we understand
the mechanism of Aging you have all the
pieces together to solve it like you
don't need to believe a whole lot you
just give it some
time there's like some outstanding
question that's like no this is going to
break the laws of physics and there's
just no like the speed of light like how
are we going get faster than speed of
light we're not sure mhm this is not the
same problem it's all the pieces are
there and the fact that it's biological
systems makes it no different than 3D
printing a treehouse or a rose oil yeah
you know nature does this already
there's several examples in nature of
certain types of jellyfish and others
where they have these remarkable
Rejuvenation abilities so like biology
has already demonstrated it's capable of
doing this so we're in a really good
place and that's why this is such an
exciting moment to be alive and if we to
just take a sober stock of like the
situation it's silly to be killing each
other it's silly to be going to war it's
silly to be killing our planet it's
silly to commit self-destruction
behavior and increase death like this is
why the 25th Century thought experiment
to me is so helpful they would look at
us and be like of course you don't die
like of course and but we're so caught
up in this moment we come up with all
these arguments on like this and that
and we're scared and but like no like
they like of course you do that one
thing you're not the first person to
come on the podcast and have a you know
somewhat
polyana perspective of of longevity and
what the future might hold I've had
Peter dandis on here Sergey
young but I think all of this you know
for me ends up in a situation where we
haven't quite delivered on the promise
yet like we've kind of inched our way up
to a certain kind of edge but when it
comes comes to the big breakthrough or
the thing that's going to change
everything there's a lot of talk but not
a lot of evidence or proof yet and then
amongst this this sort of culture of
people who are really focused on
longevity and health span extension
there's a lot of disagreement like they
don't agree on a lot and they're
quibbling over whether it's nmn or NAD
and like rap ay and all you know these
tiny little details within that world
that I can't I think we're still kind of
a ways off from what you're talking
about yeah if you
extrapolate what's happening right now
uh with how fast artificial intelligence
is
improving I don't need any evidence at
all to have a bullish Outlook that aging
is going to be solved in some near
future if you just do some rough math
and let's just say if humans were in
charge of Aging research
let's just say it would take us 200
years to try to solve aging right like
something long and like we look at our
rates of progress when you include
artificial
intelligence it works at speeds that are
orders of magnitudes faster than
humans and so if you say okay it's a
trillion times faster than what humans
can do or whatever the number is let's
discount that number and say 90% of that
compute capacity is like not really
really human intellect it's like wasted
on other stuff and so you apply some
level to that when you apply that number
to the Future over the next 10 years
with the aid of self of super
intelligence you have the equivalent of
millions of years of human effort on
Aging right so like what can we
compressed into almost no time at all
because you're adding to the
intelligence equation trillions of you
know compute into that equation so this
this is why again we can't trust our
minds to be making these forecasts we're
in a situation where the power of this
intelligence so far outstrips our
ability to model it any forecast we make
is silly then how can we trust our minds
to craft the artificial intelligence or
the
supercomputer with the adequate safety
measures to ensure that its priority is
the survival of the human race if we
can't trust our minds with our own daily
habits how can we trust that we even
have the capacity to foresee what might
go arai with the you know the birth that
we're giving to something that has a
level of intelligence we can't even
comprehend don't
die okay I mean right like now of course
it's circular in that regard now of
course it's like it's more nuanced
because what if don't I mean right and
it means hundreds of different things
and there's trade-offs so it's really
complicated but again if you have to
take this incredibly complicated
question how do we agree on one
thing and right now you know we don't
agree on don't die we kill ourselves we
kill each other we kill the planet we
are a violent species killing everything
around
us and that's why this is such a
relevant
Revolution it's so simple it's like
right in front of our face for those who
are building AI
I would feel much better if they're not
actively killing themselves if they're
sufficiently self-aware that they're not
proactively moving themselves towards
disease and death that inside of them
they have the
philosophy this is the thing that
underpins everything we're building
together in
society it's not about dominance it's
not about wealth accumulation it's not
about conquering territory it is a
change a fundamental change of our
existence you know my bullish spot aging
all I can say is I look at the models
and like I want to be around for the
possibility but it seems interesting
that like yeah uh we could be around for
it so how old are you 46 46 um and
you've
been actively engaged in in this
protocol and its refinements for three
years how long at this point yeah almost
three years so explain what the
blueprint protocol is we're an hour and
a half into this we haven't even gotten
into what it is that you actually do
which you could find in a million other
interviews you've done and you've made a
zillion videos about yeah really simply
stated is uh I do what everyone does
every day which is I try not to die and
so I just simply said what if I tried to
become the best in history at not dying
and so the way we did that is we said
I'm going to become the most measured
person in human history the world
champion of not dying yeah yeah exactly
so we're gonna measure every single
thing about my body everything we can
you thousands of data points we're going
to look at scientific literature we're
going to say okay how is the body dying
and then we're going to say what can we
do to stop the body from dying MH and
that's what we've done we've just tried
to become best in the world and not
dying to do this you have deployed
copious resources I think something like
$2 million a year I don't know you know
whatever a lot of money right like
you're all in yeah and of course you're
not doing this alone you you have a team
of people who are advising you so before
we even get into the practices and the
protocol itself how did you go about
identifying the experts and recruiting
them to be participants in this yeah
like who are these people and why did
you pick them over others yeah your
point is correct you said that every
anti-aging specialist disagrees right
that's that's why I'm asking this
question everyone disagrees with
everyone and so what we were trying to
do is to say how would you potentially
punch through the noise because while
everyone's debating these topics like NR
versus nmn cold plunger not like
whatever you're trying my mom and my dad
want to know what to eat for breakfast
MH and there's like everyone's kind of
in that space and so we said okay the
way we're going to do this is we're just
going to do me as n of one and you can
criticize it and say well that's not a
population level study it's only one not
applicable whatever still I'd rather do
this than I would hang out in
never-ending debate land it also gives
people people who are observing what
you're doing like an emotional
connection to it and a weigh in rather
than just reading a study or a report
because yeah you're so transparent in
sharing everything you're doing every
single day what's working what's not
working what we decided to abandon the
new thing that you're playing around
with that it's storytelling and that's
what gets people engaged and so they
have you're like a Locus like we can
just look at what Brian's doing maybe
it's n of one maybe there are things
that we can extract from his experiences
but I think you know saying I'm going to
be this living experiment is the best
way to create interest in what's
happening yeah okay I would say
blueprint is the best health protocol
developed in
history prove me wrong with your data we
can now say that I know you've said that
many times has anybody come back to you
with a bunch of data and challenge you
no one in the world has done it no one
has uh measured themselves like me no
one's come with the competing model I'm
three years in I'm still all by myself
you know people may be reading papers
and saying like do this thing and that
thing no one and you know like it's hard
uh it's expensive so there's barriers to
do it but still like I mean and if
someone beat this it would be the best
thing ever like I would absolutely
celebrate it because that would just
level up what you're doing exactly it's
not a threat it's like it's an ad
exactly and I work with people
extensively to help help them try to
beat me so like I really want others to
come up and improve better ways of doing
it that's how we lift everyone like the
objective here is not to be number one
the objective here is to be a zero
that's a concept I guess I haven't
played like it really is this is about
thriving as a species this is not about
being me trying to be ranked number one
rank being ranked number one is like an
oldfashioned idea it's just a former
version of being homo sapian it's not
relevant going forward back to the
experts who are these people and why did
you select them yeah so the principal
architect on the project is Oliver zolan
he's 29 years old and I was interviewing
a bunch of people
and he stood out to me we connected and
we instantaneously just kind of got
locked in for life it was like it was a
really great meting of minds and he had
this approach where he said basically
you
can't understand and treat aging unless
you do it at the organ level you have to
focus on the heart and understand what
is the anatomical nature of the heart
and what is the function of the heart
you have to age it out and you have to
do the same for the lungs the same for
the kidney and the pancreas unless
you're doing things on an organ by organ
basis like you really can't structurally
solve aging and I loved his methodical
approach it was mathematical in nature
it was rigorous it was Quantified and
then he and I have built out a team of
people all over the world that
specialize in the various organs so
we'll find World experts in every organ
area or biological process and we work
with them and we just refine these
things continually so he's like your
Chief of Staff chief medical officer
yeah he's a Chief Architect yeah so
let's get into the various practices uh
obviously it breaks down into sleep
nutrition exercise supplements some
pharmacology some medical interventions
lots of testing you talk about skin care
Hair Care Dental Care is basically
everything right but I want to begin
with sleep because that is the most
important thing I think you would agree
with that and I think that sleep is
really a trojan horse here so talk a
little bit about the importance of sleep
and how you practice sleep hygiene yeah
I know when I'm not well rested I feel
half
dead I feel inebriated you know I feel
compromised I'm honory I feel snippy so
uh the difference between a good night
sleep and a bad night sleep is just
nothing changes my conscious existence
more it's unbelievable the difference
when you have an extraordinary night of
sleep yeah problems seem to get solved
without stress your creative capacity is
through the roof your ability to
navigate obstacles like everything is
easier yeah it is like a superpower and
I've had so many occasions where I'm
having one of those days and I think I
would literally pay any amount of money
to be able to replicate this and feel
this way every day and I have gone to
Great Links Brian not not as far as you
but my sleep hygiene routine is pretty
[__] extensive I sleep outside in a
tent like I do things that you don't
even do and my sleep score on the whoop
is pretty good like I'll hit 100 you
know once or twice a week and I'm in the
90s on average or at the high 80s which
is probably good in the context of the
western world yeah but it is very rare
that I would hit 100% even two days in a
row but you have hit 100% for over 6
months months eight months without a
single day I think I've missed like
three or four days yeah I cannot even
imagine being able to do that or what it
must feel like to feel that good every
single day yeah I love it yes to
everything you
said here's the thing people think sleep
hygiene begins with you know when it
starts to get dark and you're thinking
about going to bed sleep hygiene begins
as soon as you open up your eyes in the
morning you have to start getting ready
for that evening experience and despite
all of the things that I've done I have
not oriented my life with the rigor that
you have every single thing that you do
every day all the choices you make about
the food when you eat what you're eating
the type of exercise that you're doing
Etc really is all a function of of
trying to get you prepared for the best
night of sleep possible yes my entire
life is about sleep so when people say
like if I could just do the Sleep part
of blue this is why I say it's a trojan
horse because in order to get 100% sleep
score every single day you actually have
to do every other thing in the blueprint
protocol to achieve that exactly you're
you're you're ex you're exactly right
there was this uh reporter that wrote an
article recently for GQ I was at this
anti-aging conference and uh this person
who interviewed me said you know like
what is is the number one thing you do
for you know anti-aging and this
reporter like she told the story like so
people they like listening like what's
Brian Johnson gonna say about this thing
is he gonna say like some peptide or you
know Sono or whatever protocol and then
he says sleep and she said then like the
crowd just has this Collective sigh of
disappointment right because it's much
sexier to talk about Rapa my yeah
whether that was true or not but she was
just like everyone is so disappointed
with my response but you know like I
don't know how to communicate more that
everything revolves around sleep nothing
changes existence more than sleep you
have more willpower you have more zest
for life you have more energy yeah I
just everything falls apart without
sleep I don't know how to communicate
any better yeah and when people want to
hear you elaborate on that the focus
tends to be on the blackout curtains and
the type of sheets and the air purifier
that you have in the room and the
temperature of the room and those are
all fine and well and important and play
their part but to really appreciate it
you have to you have to actually embrace
the entirety of the program yeah yeah
exactly right I mean I think we're all
competing for status and Power in
society you know like in all of our own
little circles and places and there's so
much mythology caught up in the hero
being sleep deprived and sleeping under
the desk and going days without sleeping
it's so built into the psychology that
people are trying to signal to others
I'm worthy of being respected I'm worthy
of this status I'm worthy of being
admired I'm worthy of this mythology so
they're doing things to play The Script
because they think it generates the
respect of others and in their mind they
may believe it too like this is how
genius has achieved you know I can think
of so many examples of people who have
done this and so it's so deep in our
psychology that sleep deprivation is
somehow positive that that's what stops
most people from adopting it that hustle
porn culture and notion of sleep is in
its Twilight like I feel like we've
really gone a long way towards raising
awareness around that like that shifted
a lot even in the last couple years I
think I concur yeah just even like when
I talk to my friends like they'll come
to me and say like I want this so badly
we have to engage in a therapy session
where I'm like what's up how's it going
and then we dig into deep into their
psychology and they uncover and unravel
that they really are trying to be on
mythology level with their levels of
accomplishment now it takes a lot of
vulnerability for the person to be that
honest but like once we do that in
private and they're like oh my God this
is totally unnecessary I can achieve my
objectives of ambition and status and
power and wealth and success and I don't
have to do this sleep deprivation thing
and it's so liberating for them they
actually become better at their craft
but it's not obvious like it's on the
surface it's very very hard to see that
you're playing out scripts which goes
back to the first thing we talked about
what Fishbowl are you in right now we're
all in fishbowls which one are you in
you're playing out the scripts of other
people you don't realize it but that
you're owned by it whatever I'm trying
to create and share with the world is
only as valuable as the extent to which
I suffered to create it which leads to
unhealthy choices around rest and
recovery and self-care huh and it's very
difficult to break that delusion yeah
you acknowledge this in yourself sure
interesting but as they say in in
Alcoholics Anonymous self-awareness will
Avail you nothing like having a
self-awareness around it doesn't
necessarily mean you're making a
modification to that behavior I could
really benefit from Outsourcing a lot of
what my mind is telling me what to
do and I do I just do it with other
humans yeah you know my super
intelligence is a panel of people who
keep me on track right and there's a
democratic aspect to that like I don't
want my brain to be a monarch
I create you know a Congress of people
who are smarter than I in various areas
of life from relationships to Athletics
to diet Nutri whatever it is you know
and this podcast is also an experiment
of that like I invite people on who know
things that I don't and I learn from
them and they become people in my life
that I can call upon to run my decisions
by but you know it's really through pain
and suffering that I got to a place of
willingness to submit to that to
disabuse myself of the notion that my
instincts are are guiding me
appropriately and to develop the
humility to allow other people to weigh
in on my decisions it's amazing like you
basically you're doing this in your life
already You're Building Systems of
intelligence that are superior to Native
abilities so if another human is better
at doing a given thing than you you
adopt that mhm or if you run that
decision by a panel of people and
there's a consensus yeah then that's
probably a good uh metric yeah so like
we're all playing this game today
already like we're already continually
in this game of upleveling our systems
of intelligence everyone's trying to be
their best self and that's just we're
just going to do more of the same in the
future so when we talk about AI it does
seem very jarring and new and different
but it's actually no different than what
we do already today we're just taking
the baby steps when you're in the panel
of getting opinions if you find a
superior way of reasoning through a
problem you adopt it right it overrides
your conscious mind your mind's like
actually that's better MH so you're
already doing it
sometimes yeah not always yeah yeah yeah
not always it's like yeah I know I
should do that but I'm GNA do it this
way yeah you know how many times you
gonna bang your head against the wall
yeah you know which is why pain can be
such a powerful signal yeah cuz
sometimes you have to be in pain to see
another way yeah so like me individually
I view my current self not living for me
right now I view me as in service of My
Future Self so I imagine like Brian who
lives in who exists in the year
2050 where super intelligence is
omnipresent whatever that thing is I am
in service of that Brian I want that
Brian to have that experience more than
anything else more more than me having a
temporary pleasure right now more than
me acquiring some I really view myself
in service of My Future Self because now
if we didn't exist in this time and age
I lived in the 1800s I wouldn't have
thought like that I would have been like
the omnipresent this is the only moment
that matters but this is the first time
it's ever happened in history that
basically things are changing so fast
that our future self could be
unrecognizable from our current selves
that's never been the case that's a
practice though that is counter to human
intuition like humans are not very good
about thinking about or forecasting into
the future I mean if we were listen
heart disease kills most people yeah
right that's that's the number one
killer so if we really thought about our
heart health or we cared about what we
would be experiencing in our 70s when we
are in our teens and our 20s we would
not be eating foods that are bad for our
heart but that's not the way that our
society is oriented and it's not really
the way our minds work like tell
teenager that he needs to be concerned
about something that's going to happen
to him when he or she is 70 years old
and they will dismiss you immediately
exactly exactly talk about your approach
to nutrition calorically and you know
how you make all of this work yeah I
brought you some food oh you did good
did do we want to do that we bring that
out yeah get you some food and I'll tell
you how it came about cool okay cool
this is the just nutty right yeah yes we
have
strawberries raspberries
raspberries and macadamia nut walnuts
macadamia nuts and walnuts black seeds
that's some pea protein make sure you
stir it up a little bit it can get
caught in the throat otherwise
pomegranate juice sunflower
lechon yeah it's quite
good and is this what you would eat as
your first meal or is this more like a
dessert that's number two number two
yeah I eat vegetables for
breakfast that's great the origin of
this we we pose the question if the body
could speak what would it ask for MH and
that's what we've done so this is this
diet is 2,250 calories and every calorie
has had to fight for its
life everything we have has a clinical
endpoint we measure it if it's doing its
job great if it's not it's replaced we
try to justify the presence of every
single thing well if you think longevity
experts disagree the world of nutrition
if it's anything it's a [__] storm of
people arguing with each other about you
know what's in our best interest from a
health perspective so good luck trying
to find consensus there but the truth is
if you really look at the science
there's more agreement than it would
appear if you're like in the kind of
nutrition ecosystem of social media how
did you arrive at these meals and these
recipes and these types of foods as the
things that are going to advance your
goals all of it's based upon gold
standard scientific evidence we looked
at every single lifespan and health span
study ever done we prioritized each one
according to its effect size we looked
at each one using 15 bio statistical
criteria and so we tried to assess what
evidence can we trust the most M and
then we started implementing it and then
we would measure my body simultaneously
here's my starting point here's after
you know a month of adherence 3 months 6
months and we just repeat that loop
again and again and so the most
compelling thing about blueprint is I
now have my threeyear results you know I
have hundreds of biomarkers MH like for
example my speed of Aging is slower than
97% of 46y olds slower than 80 I think
88% of 18y olds my cardiovascular
capacity is at top 1.5% of 18y olds my
bone mental density total bone mental
density is in the top .2% of 30y olds so
and there's like a dozens more of those
markers so even if a Critic wants to say
ah I don't believe in total bone mle
density because of blank blank blank you
still have to knock off the chart a few
of the Dozen markers the aggregation or
the accumulation of all of these markers
taken together it is the most
robust outcome in
history no one has ever put together
this level of measurement this level of
riger and this level of evidence never
and so let's just say in a few years
time we blow past this and we have far
superior models which would be the best
thing this is still in the world right
now where no one can agree on anything
and people just want to the simple
answer what do I have for breakfast or
what can I eat for lunch I've given them
an answer the first time in human
history where someone can say here you
go so you eat three meals a
day the final meal dinner time is at
11:00 a.m. 11:00 a.m. is the last food
that you intake for the day yeah why so
early
sleep see if I am hungry at night I have
a hard time sleeping yeah this is my big
problem Brian yeah okay so cool so I
always try to be very cautious and say
okay I do this but like you do you and
like maybe I want to get into the end of
One Versus what is universal here yeah
exactly so I always try to be like look
for me I tried it out this is the result
of hundreds of different uh trials but
like you do you maybe you're different
everybody around me that has tried this
has come back to the earlier they eat
the better they sleep I don't have a
single example of someone who eats late
and still Nails their sleep wow you may
be the first person that you know that
does it I doubt it it's discomfort you
know it's just like anything you know
when you break a bad habit it's
uncomfortable and you fight against it
and you resist it and then you acclimate
to it and then you're glad you did and
life is better yeah my my son so my
17-year-old my 16-year-old started this
he went through a year of triing this
you know like when you're 16 your
metabolism is just jamming sure and so
he experiences intense hunger pains and
so he really struggled because six or
seven of R around he'd be like just
dying and so he has been working on that
and lo and behold he's found out the
earlier he pushes that the better his
sleep gets wow so he's just had to
negotiate it but again like I'm totally
open to other people having different
routines it's just everyone around me
has slowly migrated gred back and it's
really my resting heart rate okay a few
things like if I right before I go to
bed if my resting heart rate is about 46
I'm almost guaranteed a perfect night
sleep like really strong Rim really
strong deep very little light no alcohol
and I've had you know 30 to 60 Minutes
to wind down mhm I can't go straight
from hard charging work right to hitting
the pillow I have to have some
separation to get my nervous system calm
down if I can get a few of those things
in place like like clockwork perfect
sleep it's amazing wow do you ever just
lay in bed starving though no I'm pretty
accustomed to it now I think in the
early days I really had a wrestle with
that discomfort mhm and yeah I've
normalized to it 2250 calories a day
that number was identified because it is
an adequate amount of calories while
running a 10% caloric deficit every
single day so you're eating 10% less
than your body's physical IAL needs
every single day so what is the thinking
behind that yeah so there's reasonable
evidence around caloric restriction uh
it's not a solve topic it's suggestive
that it may be good for you and Mak
stand life and healthspan so we do adopt
it initially it was on 20% I got too
skinny I lost too much weight so we bum
I've seen some of those videos yeah you
were looking pretty gaunt for a minute
there yeah it's pretty fun to look back
now I mean I've been like five different
humans yeah in this three years I look
back you the long hair with the braid
you had like you know lot yeah it's like
Interview with a Vampire that's the
clickbait YouTube title for this
podcast yeah even I look at myself I'm
like who is that guy you know it's like
I'm so different than I was before yeah
but so the 22 2250 uh what we found uh
interestingly is we have my speed of
Aging measured almost monthly for the
past two years and the speed of Aging
clocks are just getting better and
better at uh we now have a 16 organ uh
clock which just outperformed a bunch of
others but we saw that when I changed
from 20% caloric restriction to 10 it
didn't change my speed of Aging so we
didn't achieve benefits on that marker
now that's not to say that we had
benefits we didn't get for the heart and
the lungs we're looking at the whole
body but we think that 10% color
Contrition is basically we get the best
of it without having to go too far
you're confident in the accuracy of
these biological clocks cuz I've heard a
lot of kind of grousing around yeah
around whether these are reliable
indicators of anything the skepticism is
absolutely valid phenotypic markers are
much better they're gold standard these
clocks are still silver standard
absolutely true we trust them
increasingly more because the patterns
we see there match with other phenotypic
markers so we're building our internal
models but on their own I agree out of
the gate skepticism is warranted uh with
these new generation clocks coming out
now uh they're getting better and better
so we make sense of our protocol when we
put together Imaging MRI ultrasound
Fitness tests phenotypic markers DNA
methylation you know microbiome we put
them all together and we piece the
puzzle together then we trust it but we
don't have over L on one test the most
reliable clock then says you are how old
all in yeah we don't trust the age ones
we trust the speed of Aging more than
the others in other words looking at a
certain system and saying this is
operating in the way that a 20-year-old
yeah system would operate yeah and
gauging Age based upon data sets from
people of varying ages that's right yeah
if you look at my blood markers my blood
markers and my 18-year-old blood marker
my 18-year-old we about identical like
you can't really tell the difference
between us if you put him in an MRI and
me in an MRI his heart is definitely 18
and my heart is definitely not 18 mhm so
some things are very obvious in the
difference in the comparisons and so
this is why measurement has been the
most important part of blueprint is when
you don't have measurement anybody's
opinion is equally weighted when you
have ground truth with measurement it
dramatically simplifies the conversation
to say well here's the data but you have
to have repeated measurement over
certain durations of time you have to
have the rigor for certain controls and
that's what we've tried to do is
structure this in a way where we can
punch through the endless debate and
say like here's here's a starting point
for us to have a discussion yeah yeah
yeah I'm interested in
whether you're in a place where you feel
like you can extrapolate upon the data
that you've accumulated with respect to
yourself to speak more broadly about how
it's might be universally understood
because I have this like internal
dialogue around the protocol which is on
the one hand like I should do this I can
do this like look what's happening here
like why wouldn't you do this and then
on the other hand this other story that
Loops in my mind which is you might be
past the point of no repair like I was
very hard on my body for a very long
time I treated my body very poorly
substances terrible lifestyle habits you
name it like I've done it and then even
as a healthier person as an athlete like
I've pushed my body really hard and I've
done great things as an athlete but that
training and that racing was not
consistent with longevity you know kind
of priorities right like I may have
harmed myself beyond the point of no
repair at what point in terms of
arresting the aging process slowing it
we're not even talking about reversing
it yeah do you have a sense of of when
it's too late obviously if somebody
who's 90 is adopting the blueprint
protocol it's like yeah you know it's
unlikely to
be successful yeah in preventing them
from dying of course but even maybe at
aging cuz that ship is sailed I am
Racing for my parents to stay
alive so they both joke with me where a
new package from me arrives at their
house every day and it's a new thing to
do or a new thing to implement you know
my mom would be like Brian I just I can
only do so many things so you need to
tell me what to do but I think we should
fight for our lives
all of us and you know my dad is 70 he
went on blueprint and he called me he
said Brian I want you to know something
really important when you start
experiencing cognitive decline you don't
know it I thought I would know it like
hey I'm slipping you don't he said since
I've been doing blueprint I've come back
and I'm aware of some
loss I will do
anything to keep my mind as a
46-year-old I don't understand that I
can imagine what it might be like to be
on the situation where you're
potentially losing your mind but we did
a plasma exchange you know my son gave
me one liter of plasma I gave my dad one
liter of plasma yeah a lot a lot of
people had a lot of things to say about
that page six you know no uh no tabloid
refused the opportunity to put some ink
to that story so I did five liter five
one liter uh infusions myself from a
20-year-old donor then one from my
17-year-old so I got six total and we've
yet to be able to identify the benefit
of doing that maybe with better tools
we'll we'll be able to tease it out we
just can't see it now however when my
father took out 600 milliliters of his
plasma and took in one liter of mine his
speed of Aging lowered by
133% what and it stayed that way for it
stayed that way for six months his last
measurement was done just two two weeks
ago so we're doing a more comprehensive
analysis on this but it was one of the
most significant intervention outcomes
that this company had seen one time of
my super plasma one plasma transfusion
yeah so like it's question how many
liters one liter one liter yeah one
liter of my super plasma but like okay
so but there's a question see was it
because he took 600 milliters of his out
or was it because he had one liter of
mine in we don't know we haven't done
the experiment so there's a lot of
questions still though the results are
are solid like he's done multiple
measurements before multiple
measurements afterwards over a six-month
period of time so we trust the data at
this point and so for me are you past
the point of no return no like no one is
no matter where you're at if you look at
the time span like this line straight up
on how fast we're moving on intelligence
I don't think there's any reason anybody
should give up
hope all of us I have this thing that
like I'm gonna decline or die right on
the precipice of all these breakthroughs
that are going to extend Health span you
know by decades yeah like the last
generation to do it old school yeah I
just wrote a book and then my author's
bio I wrote that I died in the year
2478 by the last bus in operation on
planet Earth weeks
before Brian it would be such a shame if
like some accident happens to you with
all of the effort that's going into this
and and you know you just walk out on to
I don't know Lincoln or something like
that and get hit by a car Being Sober
about this isn't that inevitable if that
didn't happen would the universe be true
do all things not end an irony mhm and
so am I destined for some silly death
most likely probably most likely is it
going to be the most humorous version
probably right is it going to give
people endless Thrills on the internet
most likely you know like that is the
most likely outcome yeah but to like
already Embrace that like makes it less
ironic I suppose I mean it just is it
like we look at history it's just life
is irony yeah back to the food for a
minute so one thing about your protocol
is it's entirely plant-based you've
you've done this by choice but what is
your reason for being 100% plant-based I
hope that compassion is a scaling law of
intelligence so Evolution created us we
are creating super intelligence and as
we do that I hope that compassion is a
fundamental tenant of this intelligence
for our own sake I hope that that that
compassion's sake I think that if we can
figure out how to achieve our objectives
with greater
compassion we all win a much bigger
prize yeah obviate the unnecessary
suffering and for you to be thriving and
doing what you're doing you know in your
gym and you know displaying the
biomarkers and the blood markers that
are demonstrating transparently you know
how your body is responding to these
types of foods I think that's a really
powerful message to the person who
believes or is duded into the idea that
if you want to be strong and vital that
you have to eat animal products yeah I
mean fundamentally I guess what I'm I
really believe is we need to be what we
want AI to
become and we will build AI with all of
our biases if we're basically living a
life of accelerated dis disease Decay
and death we're going to build that into
AI whether we realize it or not it goes
back to what you're saying of like are
we going to build a dystopic future we
really need to be that thing before we
build it and that's why I I want this
don't die
Revolution to become a a global
Revolution that consumes the Earth in
like six months like not a 10-year time
frame that we as a species it just snaps
and we're like it's time it's going to
move and it happens faster than anyone
thinks is even possible and I think that
there's a possibility that it could
happen we currently think of like a
revolution like this like so far away
and there's so many barriers as you see
AI advance and it starts posing these
really tricky problems of who are we
what do we do how do we structure
Society like what does it mean to exist
anymore it's going to force us to find
new games to play
new status new power right all these new
things and if we can redirect it toward
something positive like don't die we
still get to play our games and that's
what I'm hoping happens is you've got
this inversely related structure and I
hope it Loops back into humans for the
main thing I really don't get into the
the war of meat like I don't get into
the war of anything I'm B basically just
trying to say we need to build a new
system of intelligence and let's just
follow the evidence and the data and if
we can do so with with compassion we're
all going to win in this new world re
building of course the other piece here
is all the supplements you take yeah
110 capsules a day yeah some of them are
things we've all heard of some of them
are are things we haven't I'm interested
in what you've played around with that
you found that you thought would work
that didn't work and how you came up
with this you know incredibly elaborate
long list of things that you take every
single
day let me think I guess a way into that
is to ask what percentage of all of
these supplements are safety gaps
because you're running a caloric deficit
and your kind of profile of nutrition is
relatively limited that you're making
sure you're meeting all of your needs
versus supplements that are oriented
around you know kind of progressing this
health span yeah aspect of what you're
doing yeah we've tried to build build
the perfect
diet again if you just ask the body like
hey body speak tell us what you need to
be your best self give us your your
recipe list that's what we've tried to
do with diet and supplements and we've
really taken a hands-off approach just
like measure the whole body okay so how
are you doing liver like where are your
enzymes let's image you how are you
doing with fat iron stiffness we look at
all these parameters and say okay what
is the evidence say on iron and
stiffness and enzymes and we take the
evidence we say well you here's the
following panel that sense for the liver
to be optimal we do the same thing for
the heart and for the lungs and
everything else and then that's what
generates the list and so we implement
the protocol we measure again and again
and again we're like well like okay
liver enzymes on point cardiovascular
ability on point so every single thing
and so sometimes there's a multifaceted
approach like you know garlic like you
know does a bunch of things inflamation
and other things like that so it's hard
to pinpoint one thing for a one toone
relationship it's really multifaceted
but every single thing has a destination
every thing is measured and if it
doesn't justify its existence it's out
in the measuring process and in the
testing process though you have to
really be careful about the variables
that you're introducing right because
you're doing so many different things
you get a test result how are you
supposed to know what that is correlated
to yeah it could be a new supplement
that you're taking it could be the fact
that you tried a new exercise in the gym
or you put a red light helmet on for a
little bit longer you know you're doing
a lot of things so how do you track that
yeah you're exactly right we've stacked
several things like going back to the
speed of Aging what we saw recently is
so we did a datinb and curstin cycle
that's a combo to get rid of cessant
cells so it's 50 milligrams of datinb
which is a drug used for leukemia and
then 500 milligrams of cerstin and you
do it 3 days in a row for three months
and the tools to measure cessant cells
are not great right so like we have some
primitive ways of doing it but we're not
really happy with it but one thing we
did see was it dramatically increased my
speed of Aging so the therapy even
though you're trying to clear ccent
cells in that clock there was an
increase in speed of aging and the same
thing happened we were trying to
regenerate my thymus and so I was doing
HGH 6 milligrams 5 days a week we did
achieve a 7year age reduction of my
thymus looking at fat fraction we did
three different MRIs uh which we feel
okay about we're not terribly confident
it's a kind of a new area but still
interesting that also dramatically
increased my speed of aging and so I use
those two examples to say that we are
trying many things but what's cool is
when we're doing HGH or the dista and
Curtin they are isolated in the therapy
windows and we can see what happens to
phenotypic markers we can see what
happens to measurement markers we can
see what happens to speed of Aging the
measurement robustness gives multiple
angles to slice it up and say
interesting same thing with plasma and
so this is why I think the data we have
on me is so interesting is it's a more
comprehensive view of any human in
history and even though it's not perfect
definitely some limitations and
definitely some crossover and definitely
some compound and confounds like sure
true also better than anything in
history as this continues to develop and
you add and subtract you know from this
equation there must be situations where
there are compromises that you have to
make because yes you could take this
supplement and it has this positive
benefit but it also has a slight
negative benefit on this other thing but
if you combine it with this you know it
makes it better or wor like these things
they don't function in isolation right
they all have like sort of they're all
dependent upon each other and how they
interact with each other and what might
be good for one system has a deleterious
impact on some other system so it's
really about how they all work together
and what the net effect of that is and
that's got to be a very complicated
computation what a fantastic a question
amazing so there's uh like a pretty
large segment of society that you know
that observes this thing and they'll be
like let me just do what he's doing well
they'll say like you're so white you
must be unhealthy you know it's like
like you're so pasty you must be
unhealthy or they'll say like your
facial fat volume is not high enough you
must be unhealthy so there's like this
General perception of like I don't know
they use their eyes they're trying to do
it that's like one layer another layer
is you start looking at all the data and
you get in there M I think what's
interesting is aging is a game of
whack-a-mole so we do the dtib and
curstin to get rid of my zombie cells
and it raises my speed of Aging it
increases it right bad situation we do
the HGH to try to regenerate my thymus
it does it but it raises my speed of
Aging so exactly what you said is it's a
wacka so what is so cool about we've
accomplished is even in this game of
wack-a-mole where you do one pos
positive thing and then a negative thing
happens we've been able to achieve Elite
level of muscle and fat and
cardiovascular and speed of aging and
and and and and and just goes on and on
like we've optimized for like 20 things
that compete with each other because
it's not like you just do one thing and
the whole body is like great it's a
trade-off space and it's very
complicated and that's what I think like
almost no one gives us props for having
optimized for all those variables at the
same time it's really the conversation
like he looks pasty therefore this must
be a bad situation and so it just
doesn't translate not yet and I think it
would be cool if those who can observe
it would speak up because people are
trying to make sense of it they have no
idea if this is legitimate or not or
like if we should talk about it but I
think it's the most impressive thing you
ever done have you had some of these
longevity doctors reach out to you to
solicit their input or to be criticized
like what has that been like yeah
recently Time magazine article that was
written interviewed several longevity
experts and they all dunked on me and
their argument was yeah so near belli uh
he made the comment I went to a
conference and he said Brian showed up
he didn't look very healthy we were all
kind of concerned about him then another
Eric verden said something like this
idea of going after uh the aing being
something we can go after I forget the
exact quote but like a little bit of a
dunk on the Endeavor and then the other
gentleman who runs the USC School of
gerontology I forget his name right now
you have to think this in context
because the reporter wants to create the
conflict so she's trying to drum up the
conflict so it's not entirely fair to
say that they only said these things
it's probably only true to say that she
took the things that they said that
created the the sharpest contrast and
most conflict so it's not entirely fair
to say these things but still they said
enough to dunk on me which is
interesting and it's totally expected in
a field that uh is like this you're
going to have a variety of different
opinions expected and that's their job
is to be skeptical it's their job to uh
raise questions others haven't so it's
fine it's to point out that it's
definitely not like we're riding into
the world of anti-asian and people are
like amazing know it's met with quite a
lot of resistance uh because it's their
domain of expertise and so and it's
fruitful and it's productive that's a
very healthy relationship to criticism I
think and a mature one I think the
difference
is you are you know not only using
yourself as the guinea pig you're
approaching this holistically by
exploring every aspect of what it means
to live in the world and what would need
to be done to kind of take out this
insurance policy on extending your life
versus slides under a microscope in a
lab studying cins and certain you know
physiological Pathways all of which is
great and fine but I think within the
scientific Community there's a sense
that the solution will be found in
solving a very particular like
biochemical pathway as opposed to
reorienting not only every lifestyle
habit yeah but also your whole mindset
around how you interface with the world
think about yourself and think about the
future of the planet and Humanity which
is you know kind of like what you're
doing right it's a different way
into the same field I guess you're
exactly right we are actually working on
different problems blueprint appears as
if we're trying to solve aging it's not
true I'm trying to solve for don't die
as a
species I'm trying to solve
for at the highest possible level like
if we just take stock of where we're at
we're in a dicey situation with our
biosphere right like how serious is our
climate situation right now we don't
know we have no clue we don't know what
the compounded effects are going to be
we don't know how catastrophic could
become and how fast we saw Co leveled us
as a species and we're walking into this
catastrophic climate situation like I
don't know this is like a level of
insanity so we have that going on we
have weapons that we can annihilate each
other with our fingers are on the
trigger kind of scary and we're building
AI of like this total unknown of what
this thing could be we have really
really significant challenges in front
of us and I'm trying to say if we size
up the situation that after 13.8 billion
years we're conscious and we're here and
we have a chance to create this
remarkable existence let's try to get
our stuff together a little bit sober up
in this moment and actually create
something spectacular and so that's the
game I'm trying to play and it all
hinges upon this one philos opical thing
of don't die if I can demonstrate with
blueprint that maybe there's a chance
that we could you know radically extend
our lifespans it might be enough to
shift the Zeitgeist and snap it and say
you know what we're in we're going to
play the game don't die because if death
is no longer inevitable everything about
our reality is going to change
everything about how we think is going
to change everything is going to change
about our existence and it can happen so
fast how do you scale this n of one into
a broader movement I I assume that's why
you put yourself out there and you're
doing podcasts Etc because you know
driving all the way over here and
driving back it's not an ideal way to be
living your blueprint protocol
lifestyle yeah a few
things over the past few months we've
taken blueprint and we've put it we made
it into a product and so when I first
started this thing it was really explore
the scientific Frontiers I did it for
two years no one cared then there was
this article in Bloomberg it kind of
blew up and it's just kind of Taken on a
life of its own and the most common
response I hear is make it easy to do
like right now it's so unapproachable
it's un not doable it's too extreme I
can't do it so it just doesn't feel like
it's actually doable by anybody some
people do it but like you know it's
tough so people have said make it easy
so we spent the past um eight months now
building up this product and we're going
to launch it in 60 days so it's going to
compete for the uh calorie for calorie
doll for dollar the most nutritious food
program ever built in
history so prepackaged meals food
delivery what is it it'll be extra
version olive oil uh it will be pills
powders drinks Foods so basically
allinone just we'll ship it to you and
you just eat this and consume these
things exctly we're going to say like
we're going to pack your lunch mhm don't
trade with the other
kids right but but you know like we're
trying like we got you and so the
starter kit we have about 1, to 1,00
calories a day which we take care of the
person's left with having to solve for
about thousand a day we have some fast
followon products afterwards that will
solve for the whole day and what we're
trying to say is we've got you and we're
going to give you the most nutritious
thing you could ever possibly imagine
and we're going to do so at a cost
that's going to be cheaper than what
you're doing right now we're going to
actually save you money and so I think I
love this because if you look at
technological AUST over the past few
decades all the focus has been on
computers and the internet and the
Marvel of all this stuff meanwhile we've
been martys for this progress meanwhile
we've continued to age and die as we've
always have we get worse in fact like
the situation is not great with our
mental health where are the societal
scale human Improvement projects and I
think this is this is one uh this is
like we are fullon going to change the
landscape of how we deal with nutrition
now getting nutrition like done right is
the great first step but we want to
revolt against this culture of
self-destruction that's fast food and
junk food and all these self-destructive
behaviors so we're excited about that we
think it really is like the revolution
is in these daily things we do what we
put in our body and there's nothing more
intimate than what you put in your body
right that's a good way of scaling
because I think it does speak to the
average person who maybe watched a
YouTube video or two of yours and is
overwhelmed just like look I just you
know tell me what to eat and that gets
into the problem however of what is n of
One Versus what is responsibly
extrapolated from this protocol and
there's only so much right and so maybe
it is in the three meals a day that you
know there's some universality to that
but then it gets dicey in terms of
supplementation and all these other
things that you go into but one thing I
would say which I should have said at
the outside set is that in furtherance
of this discussion around transparency
like the blueprint website it's all
there like and you've organized it in a
way that makes it very easy to kind of
understand what you're doing you just
List It All Out here's everything I do
every single day here are the recipes
this is the caloric breakdown here is
every single supplement and they're
hyperlink to Amazon so you can just you
know get them and here's my exercise
routine and here's the video where I go
through the like all of it here's my
nighttime routine here's my dental like
my hair Rejuvenation routine my skincare
routine like it's all there yeah so we
don't have to Canvas all of that in
today's conversation that would actually
be kind of a boring podcast it's just
more philosophical which gives you a
context for the why which I think is
really important because the what
doesn't really mean anything unless you
really understand the why yeah but this
is all long-winded way of saying that I
just you know I appreciate the
transparency of it and the fact that
it's all listed out there and as I said
to you at the beginning of the podcast
our Ellis Tyler's 28 he's been having a
few health things that that have
challenged him and he's found a lot of
soless and guidance in in what you've
shared and it's interesting because like
I'm kind of a thing in the health world
right like you can't hear it you know
it's like sometimes you can't hear it
from your parents you know what I mean
and and not for nothing you're doing it
next level anyway so you're a better
role model to him than am by a long shot
but he's really been positively impacted
by what you shared and we've started
preparing blueprint meals and you know
we've done we've made a lot of changes
in our home uh for which you've you've
been responsible so I just wanted to
kind of publicly acknowledge that and
you know I think that it's really cool
what you're doing like as resistant as I
was initially when I was watching what
was going on with you I was like who is
this guy he's a little bit weird I don't
understand this like my whole tune has
changed I'm like thank God he's doing it
like you're sort of this modern-day
Explorer like an astronaut you know out
there like going places you know no one
else is going and then reporting back
like this worked this didn't work oh
this is exciting you know and we can all
join in and follow along in in real time
and I think that that is like a lootable
investment of your time and resources
for Humanity Thank you very much I I
can't tell you how much I appreciate
that kindness yeah it is really cool and
I guess you know I'm not quite done it
sounded like I was finishing the podcast
I have a couple more things I want to
ask you I guess I'd be remiss in in
letting you go before asking you know
what's on the horizon or what's the test
that you're excited about that either
doesn't exist yet or you're about to do
or you know what is the kind of future
near future Horizon that you're inching
towards that you think might make a
difference and how you're interfacing
with all of this yeah I really have uh
moved on from the basics of the
blueprint protocol cuz I think we've
done a pretty good job mastering diet
sleep exercise and I really want to go
after
culture as like for example last
Saturday I posted on social media I'm
doing a trail run I'm doing a trail run
saw that come join me yeah and 11 people
joined me and we we had a fantastic time
we became friends uh we had a great
conversation it was really wonderful
we're all strangers to each other but it
was such a wonderful experience and uh
having done that I post it again on
Wednesday and uh instead of capping it
CU I capped it to a pretty small group
we have like 150 people who've responded
and so tomorrow morning on this little
teeny Trail we're going to go run
together and I've been thinking all week
of like what is the ritual we do
together like I'm playing with this idea
like you know what coordinated movements
we do together to feel bonded how do we
feel like we're in sync how do we feel
like we're a tribe how do we feel like
we're really into this and like this
don't die thing is like it's real and
like we we fill each other's energy but
I'm really trying to go after being
healthy is very hard the pressures to do
the self-destructive behaviors are so
strong and you are at risk of losing
friendships you're at risk of being made
fun of you're at risk like it's really
painful to not do these things to not
comply with them there is a social cost
huge you're living your life at Cross
purposes with cultural norms exactly and
like nothing stings more than not being
part of a tribe nothing hurts more than
your friends reject you like it's awful
and so I'm wondering if I can start
doing some cultural events uh like some
parties and some runs and some things
and convening people to say you know
what you're not alone we can do this
together we can derive strength from
each other I've written a book don't die
which walks through this philosophical
conversation so it's almost like we had
dinner together I broke myself out into
multiple characters and it's a dialogue
between the characters about all these
ideas one character makes the argument
of like no way Free Will is absolutely
the way to go about doing things I'm
never going to relin the power of my
mind it's an awful idea and the next
character is like just hold tight just
like listen to this idea just for a
minute and breathe through it and it
just swings back and forth to try to
capture the various perspectives of how
people think about these ideas most
people
presume that large scale societal change
happens over some longer time
Horizon I think it's really possible
that this could happen faster than any
of us imagined and so want to start
laying the groundwork to say we can do
this because as a species we're kind of
beat down do we really trust our
institutions like we're at war with each
other like social media is kind of awful
like people are really ugly to each
other we say a lot of mean things it's
really hard to be healthy I don't feel
great like it's just really hard right
now in society and like in the same way
we imagine unadulterated ambition for
our technology can we start having that
same aspiration for ourselves can we
start feeling bullish about the future
Being Human versus like succumbing to Ai
and where it's going to be on universal
basic income but we're all useless like
how do we create some Grand Vision for
ourselves and motivate ourselves to
build a spectacular future we don't know
what's in store for us but why put our
tail between our legs and why just mop
into the future and it's really missing
like where's the Gusto of Being Human
where's our Gusto of doing this we love
our technology we worship our technology
we're willing to die for our technology
but where is it on The Human Side that's
where I want to focus cuz you diet gets
you so far sleep with you soar but like
we need a game to play we need to have a
want to exist like a an absolute burning
desire to exist that definitely feels
like it's lacking right now and I think
it speaks to just a general Malay fueled
by a growing sense of disempowerment in
our lives and perhaps that that speaks
to the social constraints that we're
unaware of that just drive us you know
on trajectories that feel like were
never our choice to begin with but which
we've sort of been lured into and with
that you know the creeping uh you know
increase in mental health issues and the
like like you know you mentioned earlier
when you compare Humanity to technology
and we see all these advances and what
we're able to do with tech and then you
look at humans and it's like a lot of
mental health disorders a lot of you
know increase in unhappiness and you
know people dying of all these chronic
lifestyles
like and we're just we're treating
symptoms we we're basically medicating
people but we're not really getting at
the root cause of what's causing these
diseases let alone exploring the
antithesis of that which is optimizing
Health yeah right in large part that's
because we don't have a system set up
that incentivizes that so it requires
not only outside thinking but you know
really breaking the Paradigm and
creating a new paradigm and that's a
lonely path that you're on so it's not
surprising that you're like please come
run with me on the trail because I don't
want to be the only person doing this
and if there's anyone else out there
that's doing it they probably feel you
know quite alone because you know you
have a lot of support and resources that
most people don't have the framework
that I like and understanding this is a
concept called zero ISM and so first
principal thinking is something a lot of
people know about you try to assume the
fewest number of things in a given time
frame Sherlock Holmes is a first
principal thinker Dirk gentley uh he's a
detective by Douglas Adams he's a zeroth
principal thinker where he arrives at
the crime scene and he basically is
trying to find what's
impossible so he's trying to find the
unknown unknowns MH and so if you look
throughout the history the biggest
discoveries that we've had many of the
most significant ones have been zero
principal discoveries for example like
the Earth is not the center of the
universe or special Theory relativity or
the germs are the cause of infection or
the vanishing point to allow 2D art and
3D perception they discoveries of
unknown unknowns so first principles
thinking would be knowing the knowns
yeah and zero ism is figuring out how to
know an unknown first principle is that
you've got puzzle pieces in front of you
and you're trying figure out if there's
a way to assemble this puzzle together
in some cohesive interesting way you're
trying to avoid any assumption on top of
that zero ISM you're trying to question
is there another dimension here I don't
see the application of zero ISM to the
notion of Health span is what first
principes thinking is only so helpful in
thinking about the future because we're
up against this wall of fog with super
intelligence we can can't see we can't
see past it we can't predict how it's
going to happen like when artificial
intelligence played the game of alpha go
and beat the world champion least at all
it played moves in that game that
stunned human genius so human genius has
been playing that game for thousands of
years you give that game to Ai and in a
matter of days it stuns human genius
from it just breaks their brain the
moment you apply this super intelligence
computational intellig even it's current
form not even even future forms it
breaks hum brains of what is actually
genius what is possible and so our
future is basically going to be a
continuous stream of breaking our
reality our realities have been broken
in the past of like Earth is not the
center of the universe there's little
tiny microbes cause infection Einstein
says actually Newtonian physics only you
know talks about these Dimensions
there's another dimension whoa these
breakthroughs are separated by
decades and centuries right whereas the
accelerating idity of what is to come is
staggering staggering so I call this gen
zero and this is basically to say like
hey
everybody we're right now in a moment at
the last moment where like things kind
of have been how they have been but
they're about to change radically and in
this new future we can't predict what's
going to happen we no longer have the
ability and so we're living in a zeroth
world and so gen zero is a group of
multi ethnic multinational people who
rise up and they say we are willing to
courageously step into the
future and we're willing to divorce or
open to divorce from ourselves all human
Norms all human Customs all human
thought and we're willing to say we're
wide
open about everything absolute Blank
Slate now that is impossibly hard to
think about because we have the thing
things we care about we have our
preferences we have our beliefs we have
our wants and to basically say we're
open to this being a blank slate of
existence is the most challenging thing
one could ever do I think this is why on
some degrees I get so much flak like I
think people kind of see this where I'm
I'm
proposing something that is so
fundamentally offensive at every single
layer of what it means to be human today
like you take every single thing we we
consider to be sacred and I'm
challenging that headon and I'm saying
it the reality may be the exact opposite
like the idea
that one could possibly transcend every
bias and every idea they have about the
world and themselves is again on some
level it it it goes back to this
Buddhist idea of Oneness and and of no
mind right there is like are
psychedelics a part of this because it
sounds like in order to inhabit yeah a
space of creating distance between
yourself and your assumptions and your
biases requires you know some kind of
fracture process to even approximate
yeah yeah so I think Buddhism is a
really interesting example if you look
at ideologies that have emerged
throughout history you could almost look
at the time and place the person emerged
let's just take Buddhism and if you look
on the other side what was the
technology at the time in place you
could almost predict the ideological
thing that would emerge so in the time
of Buddha they didn't really have any
technological abilities the only thing
you could do would be to close your eyes
and meditate you had no other abilities
and then when you look at the the rise
of Islam and Christianity you find this
really compelling storytelling like hey
there's this omnipotent being we have
these rules if we follow these rules we
get this prize and that storytelling
prevails for a few thousand years but
like that was really the technology of
the time and if you say right now what
is the technological ability and what
does that mean for an ideology you could
almost map the ideology and the ideology
is zero ISM it's like it's it's so
predictable because no existing ideology
in the world has anything meaningfully
to say about this moment in time where
are the major
religions in offering us practical
things about this moment on how to solve
biggest problems even with capitalism
hey capitalism what should we do with
our major problems how do you solve this
even that it it just is too shallow so
where do we look for inspiration and
structure to do it and this is what I've
been trying to F with zero ISM like
build out a philosophical structure we
can say okay like we can understand
where we're at these are practical steps
we can follow we can all cooperate
around these core ideas but I'm trying
to create the stableness of a found
Foundation of how we think about and act
in this highly uncertain situation we're
in and build something as much as we can
predict and control in the future of a
world where you know it's built around
this don't die and thriving to what
extent are you actually participating in
the building of that like we've been
talking about AI you're an entrepreneur
and you have a variety of companies that
you've founded or are heavily invested
in like are you directly invested in
this aspect of this future casting that
we've been talking about so I made a
couple hundred million from brry Van Mo
I've put everything into this I've sunk
all my money into it and it would have
been very easy to take that money and
make a lot more money you know like if I
could have just done just a normal
business you know like it's so easy to
make money with money and I really
didn't think that was the right move the
objective was to change the trajectory
of intelligence in this this part of the
Galaxy and do something that matters a
few hundred years from now which says a
lot with how much we're going to change
like to be valued in the 25th Century
like you've got to do something
spectacular and so this is really all
poured into that singular objective of
trying to do the one or two or three
things in the century that moves the
needle for the species and I've been
obsessed about this problem it just has
absolutely consumed me I think about it
non-stop I feel like you should come up
with a blueprint like a literal
blueprint for a home where the home is
designed in a way that's conducive yeah
to everything that you're talking about
yeah the systems I've been trying to
build is putting myself in someone
else's
situation I just want the food to arrive
and I want instructions on what to do
and I want for that to be solved and
then if I can start making small
decisions on prioritizing my sleep and I
start banging out 100% nights I feel
amazing about existence like if I can
get those two things right and then we
can then add on some exercise which is
great and you know something else but
just get people in a mindset where we
say we want this like we're up for it
we're down for it let's go like this is
the thing like when I was depressed you
know I really did want to end my life
like desperately wanted to commit
suicide I would have done it had it not
been for my
kids and
so there's deep inside of me this
imagination that we want to
exist no matter what
unconditionally we want to exist when
I've tried to talk about this I'm
surprised at how much push back I get
where people are like well and there's
so many things they tell me of like why
they don't want to exist like I would be
bored or I I don't want to be blank or
blank there's so much resistance to
living and I wonder in the moment again
if it we're like homoerectus like if we
really understood what it meant to exist
in 20 years time would we be like losing
our minds of like please exist like no
matter what you do please stay alive
like do we have any wisdom at all in
this moment to speak for ourselves and I
don't think I do and this is why I feel
like I'm really in the service of My
Future Self is I have have no clue what
I'm talking about I just know I need to
not die because this future thing is
like is the most remarkable thing to
happen in
history it must be hard for you to
date yeah yeah yeah would somebody have
to be on the blueprint protocol it would
be too hard if they they weren't yeah I
you know I'm single I really do want to
partner uhhuh and uh I guess I have to
be like in impossibly hard like I don't
know I just can't imagine
anybody putting up with me I just feel
like I'm like intolerable on every front
that makes me that makes me sad to hear
you say that it's kind of true right
like you you take me as like uh most
people have expectations for what's
reasonable in a relationship and I think
I just break almost everything and so I
don't know it's just like
uh I've yet to find a situation where
somebody would genuinely be happy with
me yeah so it's a pretty complicated
situation yeah yeah yeah there's a long
list of things that somebody would have
to be on board with yeah like I don't
eat after 11: and I'm in bed at 8:30 and
there's no way you're sharing a bed with
anyone like too big of a threat to the
100% streak yeah you know like there's a
a lot it's a lot a lot going on and so
when you think of it in those terms and
you're saying hey look look how happy I
am and here's what what I'm doing like
you're never saying like you should do
this too like you're doing what we say
in AA is attraction rather than
promotion like you're trying to create
an attractive model for what this might
look like but the ask is huge and I
think the social aspect of it looms much
larger than you know the Practical
implications of the food that you're
eating and the supplements you're taking
and what time you have to go to bed and
that's really what comes into play In
terms of mass adoption yeah maybe that's
why we need to scale this because you
need to find somebody to dat right we
got to grow the population for you yeah
for selfish reasons I wonder I I really
I I spend almost zero time on dating I
wonder if I actually did spend time if
what would come of it but yeah I I
genuinely want to be in a
relationship my 18-year-old and I are
like best friends it's the best
relationship does he date uh he does
yeah does see he can be the model for
you uh it's the best relationship had
you become 18 like he's showing you how
to be 18 right so when you become 18
again you can do what he's doing I
honestly there's so much about that like
I hang out with he and his friends and
we have so much fun together we just do
we play like kids it's never ending fun
like I love all my children uh
obviously we have that complication with
our past with religion where like two of
my children are kind of like yes Dad we
do love each other also kind of complex
so and we openly acknowledge it and have
that conversation but my son and I we
just P around we're just best friends
like we do everything together it's so
fluid like we're just like one thing all
the time and it is the best relationship
I've had in my entire life and it is the
most beautiful thing in the whole world
and so I guess I I know what it feels
like to be in this wonderfully beautiful
relationship and I do want it just it's
complicated to be human it's complicated
to be in a relationship yeah yeah I mean
I'm happy to hear that you have that
relationship with him but I'm I'm sorry
to hear about the constraints with your
other kids that can't be easy as you
know it will change like kids change so
fast so like it's fine yeah yeah time
will tell in seeing you in watching
videos W with you interacting with
telich I have to ask this question but I
have to know I have to know if you've
watched the TV series Foundation or if
you read the book yeah because you
realize of course that you are Empire
yeah yeah that you and your son are the
same person and that on some level I
have to think like even if it's
unconscious that you are striving to
adopt the leeace physiology because that
dude is ripped in that show and looks
fantastic and it's just a series of of
him at various ages yeah absolutely
aware totally on board yeah am I the
first person to point that out or has
that been pointed out it's pretty common
yeah I'm so I'm equally Patrick baitman
uhhuh you know yeah there's a there's a
that uh I get Dorian Gray a lot I get
elf colon from uh vampire Edward Colon
uh Prometheus MH yeah so that's a
smattering of of characters yeah right
yeah right you should make a video about
that I know you did the Mean Tweets
video but like all the sort of like uh
blueprint Role Models out there Ro
models yeah I want to do a I want to do
a Patrick bman more routine that's
pretty funny yeah Last Thing Before I
Let You Go you know I feel like you've
already kind of offered up some some
pretty profound closing statements but I
think I just want to leave you with the
opportunity
to maybe share what what we haven't
covered today that you want to leave
people with in terms of of how to think
about this and you know feel free to
correct the record on how you think
you're misperceived in the media yeah
and really just the message that you
want to speak to broadly about what
you're trying to do and the world that
you would like to see be created out of
the seeds of your efforts yeah so I
guess first is I do keep my son in a
dungeon in my basement yeah unlike what
media has reported just you guys in IV
bags you know sucking each other's blood
all day long in the dark but unlike what
media has reported his room is not 10 x
10 it's 8 by8 so that first but then
thank you very much for having me this
was one of my most favorite
conversations I've ever had oh thank you
yeah I feel like you really went there
emotionally with me like you you did it
all like you experienced the emotional
arousal of being fundamentally
challenged so deeply about everything
who you are and you were open to roll
through it and you were open to consider
other ideas and perspectives and I feel
like this is was basically the same
effect of us having dinner together or
after this we're going to hug and it's
like you know what man like we're good
we're friends we're going to do life
together like I feel like we really
connected which was amazing and that's
not always the case these are very hard
conversations to have so thank you for
being such a generous host you're
welcome and thank you y so hi friends uh
I hope this was useful I would love to
hear your perspective in the comments I
do read the comments I love to hear what
how what you perceive I also am always
trying to get better you can see that I
I really am trying my very best to
convey these complicated ideas I know
that sometimes uh I can do a lot better
so I'd love to hear your suggestions and
how we can do it but i' would say above
all I hope that we as a
species that let me just make this more
individual that each one of you so you
and
I
can rise up and choose an existence that
is potentially more spectacular than we
can imagine like this moment is so
special it is no previous generation has
ever had this opportunity and I hope
that we can be sober enough to capture
it and it's real it's here right now and
we are not powerless against the world
and all the things going on we can rise
up and so I hope we can build a
community on this and I hope we can take
advantage opportunity uh I think it
really is the most spectacular thing to
ever have happened to the human
race beautiful
man I really appreciate what you're
trying to do it takes a lot of of
courage and gumption especially to so
boldly live kind of outside the
structures of of social expectations and
you've sacrificed a lot to do this so I
think that speaks to you know the
authenticity of of of what you're trying
to achieve and I think beyond all the
talk about super intelligence and and AI
as I said earlier like I really do think
that you feel deeply you know I think
that maybe you don't even appreciate the
extent to
which the emotional piece of this is
motivating you and I would go so far as
to suggest
that that it's not the data and the
numbers and the super intelligence and
the AI but it's truly your emotional
connection to what you're doing that is
perhaps the
underappreciated superpower here that's
operating and um I think it's profound
and I'm really glad that you're doing it
and uh I just wanted to thank you for
coming here today I appreciate it thank
you very much yeah and we're definitely
going to hug it out I want to come to
your house and see the whole deal yeah
you're welcome uh I hope you come by and
I think we should put together a dinner
I think we should get a group of doing
it at 10:
a.m. what time is dinner why don't we do
it on a Saturday we'll do it like at
noon okay maybe we can do an activity
before or after cool but let's put
together an amazing group and we'll make
you know new lifelong friends absolutely
love to do it yeah thank you Brian I
mean that I appreciate it thanks peace
[Music]
Lance that's it for today thank you for
listening I truly hope you enjoyed the
conversation to learn more about today's
guest including links and resources
related to everything discussed today
visit the episode page at Rich roll.com
where you can find the entire podcast
archive as well as podcast merch my
books Finding Ultra voicing change in
the plant power way as well as the plant
power meal planner at meals. ral.com if
you'd like to support the podcast the
easiest and most impactful thing you can
do is to subscribe to the show on Apple
podcasts on Spotify and on YouTube and
leave a review VI and or comment
supporting the sponsors who support the
show is also important and appreciated
and sharing the show or your favorite
episode with friends or on social media
is of course awesome and very helpful
and finally for podcast updates special
offers on books the meal planner and
other subjects please subscribe to our
newsletter which you can find on the
footer of any page at Rich roll.com
Today's show was produced and engineered
by Jason Cameo with addition audio
engineering by Kale Curtis the video
edition of the podcast was created by
Blake Curtis with assistance by our
creative director Dan Drake portraits by
Davey Greenberg graphic and social media
assets courtesy of Daniel CIS thank you
Georgia Wy for copywriting and website
management and of course our theme music
was created by Tyler Patt traper Patt
and Harry mathys appreciate the love
love the support see you back here soon
peace peace plance
[Music]
namaste